And we're live,
ladies and gentlemen,
that's the end of the world as we know
it.
Montana has been on fire for a month.
Florida has three hurricanes headed
towards it and Houston is still have
hundreds
water.
Uh,
Houston.
Sad.
Have you been?
No,
I've just,
Ah,
you know,
a lot of my ex sitting there and she's
sending me photos and videos,
like her whole neighborhood's gone.
Her and like people have to put
everything outside for the insurance
collectors to look at it,
you know.
So there's just everyone's house has a
pile in front of it and all their stuff.
And this is like no looting please.
You know,
I saw that on TV.
Yeah.
Fuck
Dude.
It's like there's nothing stopping that
from happening for months.
Like this is the thing about like
Hurricane Irma,
like they have harvey hits Houston and
then Hurricane Irma.
Dave,
correct me if I'm wrong,
but I think they said that this is very
unusual because hurricane irma picked up
speed in the ocean,
which is a really bad sign.
They usually pick up speed in the Gulf
and the ideas that the Gulf has water
that's warmer and that's what causes it.
I don't know shit about hurricanes.
I'm totally talking out my ass.
Right.
I don't know.
I really don't understand that,
but I'm pretty sure that's what they're
saying is that this is a very unusual
storm because it actually picked up
speed and picked up size and power in
the ocean,
which means the oceans warmer.
So this could be a consequence of having
a warmer ocean is that these fucking
hurricanes could get bigger and bigger
in the ocean
and it's usually.
It's really unusual because you know you
have like a such a big storm,
like the one I hit Houston,
that's usually once a year.
Once every couple years.
It's not twice in like a month.
And then there's like what Jose's right
behind it.
That's craziness.
I think they said there's two behind it.
The other one formed in the Gulf next to
like off of Mexico,
eastern Mexico.
So it's just another one at the same
time.
Different place sitting there right now.
There could be another one forming off
the Cape in Africa where they all
usually forum,
but fuck man,
we don't.
We don't get hurricanes because it's
cold water.
Is that the logic behind it?
Yeah,
I think that's the move.
You want to live near cold water.
Just suck it up like a man and deal with
that cold water.
That water is fucking coal too.
When you get in the water and the
Pacific Ocean like,
Hey,
what is this like?
This is weird.
It's crazy cold.
Even in the middle of August,
it could be a 100 degrees in Malibu.
You get in that water and you're like,
Holy Shit,
this is fucking cold.
I've only been in it twice since I've
lived here 13 years.
The first,
I remember the first week I moved down
here,
I was like,
I'm going to the ocean.
I'm running the ocean freezing.
Never hit it again.
What does all this you're showing has
and please don't say that hurricanes and
these hurricanes,
tropical cyclones or the 2017 Pacific
hurricane season,
so these are cyclones that I guess I've
already happened this year either.
Assuming when I was pulling it up,
they were in the past like long time
ago.
I didn't know these other,
this many had already come here.
When you look at this picture,
like if you look at this picture of the
United States gives you such a way
better sense of what it really is
because that picture like because all
the browns and the Greens and because
I'm not seeing cities and because it's
like a perfect scale,
like pull back a little bit.
So you see it in scale with the ocean.
Again,
like when you're looking at that,
you realize,
oh that shit kid shift left and right a
bunch of times easy.
Like there's way more water than there
is ground.
Like that is a fucking problem.
That's a giant problem.
We're next to an enormous chunk of blue.
It's so big.
Dude.
I'll tell you,
man,
when I was living in that house in
Malibu for a couple months on the water,
uh,
rented a spot on the water.
That's when you realize you go,
oh,
that's a monster.
That's like you're living on the edge of
a world that can just reach in and
swallow you freaking out.
Did you fuck?
Yeah.
You know when it freaks you out is at
night.
At night.
It reveals its true self because like in
the day it looks beautiful.
The Sun hits it.
It seemed so peaceful.
The birds or it's flat.
You see,
you see a seal or maybe a dolphin or a
whale.
Sometimes you see a whale,
people see whales out there.
You're like,
wow,
this is crazy.
But then at nighttime when the skies
dark and the sea is black,
then you get to see what it really is
like,
oh,
this is a.
This is a whole nother world,
a world of water,
and if we can touch it,
we can go in between world and that
world is far bigger than our world.
Then I started freaking out about all
the shit that we're pulling out of that
world,
like how gross we humans,
we're,
we're just getting everything in that
world and scooping it up.
Just chopping it up and stuffed it into
cans and feed it to our pets and eating
it like left and right.
Raw Sushi whom yummy like that.
Never ending supply.
Fucked up the world of the ocean.
That is a real trip.
If you stop and think about what it
really is,
because if it was in the sky above your
head,
you'd be freaked out all the time.
You know,
if like you reached up to touch it,
he'd be freaked out.
You wouldn't want to be right next to
that thing like Jesus.
It's to alien.
I can't get.
I can't get away from it because it's
right there and it's blue and we're on
the ground.
We feel like we're in control.
We're cocky because most of the time
nothing happens.
Like no big deal.
It's right there.
I love the beach.
Like one of the beach gets sun,
cut some bruise.
So like we like flirting with death,
standing at the edge of this impossible
to control life force filled with
creatures filled with the biggest
creatures in the world,
right?
Aren't whales the biggest things on
earth.
The you know what they are,
they're the biggest living thing on
earth.
Next to this.
There's like a.
A group of mushrooms in the Pacific
northwest that are all connected in all
considered to be one enormous life form.
Yeah.
I gotta get this Guy Paul stamets.
I think that's his name.
I believe that's how you say his name
right?
He's a guy who studies mushrooms,
some mushroom scientists.
Fascinating studies,
fascinating articles and stuff online in
the Blue Mountains in Oregon.
Yeah.
There it is.
Shit.
More precisely.
A specific honeyfund gus measuring two
point four miles across in the Blue
Mountains.
It's known as the largest living
organism on earth.
Several species of fungi belong to the.
Try that word.
Our Mila Ria.
I'm Ellaria Janice.
Janice or Jenice.
How do you say that?
It's a read one.
That's what I read.
I never say,
you know,
I never used that in a conversation and
wanting to be a super pretentious.
I'd have to be like a really high to be
that pretentious.
I'm A.
I'm a malaria and malaria.
Malaria or malaria or malaria.
Jenise,
which is probably a properly rather
popularly known as honeyfund gus two
point four miles across.
I liked how they give it to us in
kilometers.
Like if you don't want to be stupid,
three point eight kilometers,
if you want to be like the rest of the
world and do everything in tens,
you fucking idiots sticking a miles and
inches.
Why?
Why do we do that?
Because we're gross parts of America
that are gross,
but like,
Nah,
we got it.
And they're like,
well we have.
We found a much better system.
It makes more sense.
It's all intends the whole world.
Use it.
Good luck.
Good luck with that fucking stupid
system.
I'll take inches.
Brow yards,
inches.
It feels good to when you're in like
other countries and you're like,
why are you going 120 miles an hour?
Oh wait,
it's a different.
So they're like 62 is like,
I want to say it's a hundred kilometers
an hour,
but I think it's actually more than
that.
I would say so always thinking it's
half,
but that's probably wrong.
Well,
I,
yeah,
I don't know.
I honestly don't know.
Is Sixty to 100 miles an hour?
100 kilometer,
100 kilometers rather 62 miles an hour.
100 sounds cooler,
you know,
kilometers or just they're better.
We're using some old king shit inches.
It'd be weird to change now though.
Like we had to be born with that.
Like it's cool dude.
When I was,
I mean I don't know about when you were
in high school but when I was in high
school they were trying.
There was a real push to get people to
use the metric system that I don't think
exists anymore.
I don't know,
but I mean maybe it was just the schools
that I was in.
I would like to talk to other people
that are like my age that could remember
like the 19 eighties because of the 19
eighties I think that they were trying
to push the metric system.
I think I kind of caught on the tail
end.
I don't remember it at all from scratch.
The United States is now the only
industrialized country in the world that
does not use the metric system and its
predominant system of measurement.
Most Americans link,
I think that our involvement with metric
measures measurement is relatively new,
but it's not right.
They.
What year did they try and do it?
Nineteen 75.
See the metric conversion act of 1975?
Yeah,
that's what I remember.
Dude,
share Ford.
Yeah.
They were trying that because maybe it
wasn't.
Maybe I wasn't in high school.
Maybe it was before high school.
I think it was.
I was looking something up the other
day.
I think it was when you asked are the
president's allowed to change the,
uh,
White House or something.
And I think it was Ford that added solar
panels to the White House.
I was looking up and then the next
president,
which might've been Nixon,
took them out and they didn't have them
re-installed and thick until Obama was
there,
like whatever,
five years ago.
So it was like 25 years of no solar
panels when they already had them.
We were already headed that way.
Super Weird.
That is weird.
You see the new apple campus,
uh,
that they're gonna show,
I guess next week,
next Tuesday when they haven't seen much
of it.
But I know that it's supposed to be some
insanely impossible,
huge,
crazy place.
It looks like a spaceship.
It's now finished.
They have like drone footage that you
can like just go round.
It looks just like a round donut
spaceship and the whole a roof.
A solar collectors.
So that powers itself.
Look at that thing.
Yeah.
That might be a computer image of.
I think that is.
Wow.
Who Cares?
Back in on the computer image.
That's insane.
That's.
It must be so cool to have the kind of
money where you could just build
something like,
well you guys want to do some shit bro.
Yeah.
It's make a fucking giant apple
spaceship.
She would make it the shape of an apple
too.
Colony.
They could.
They could have easily made that thing
in apple,
but then they would have never been able
to sell it yet.
Well yeah,
exactly.
It's going to go to like a tire company
next.
Never be able to sell it.
Man.
You know,
if they do,
no one wants to buy your stupid apple.
You don't like the touch bar on your Mac
book.
I've not even seen one in person yet.
Some.
This is what I think.
I don't think it's necessary.
I think it's kind of cute,
but it does a lot of different stuff
that I never use and um,
maybe it's me,
but also there's like a Siri button that
I accidentally pressed all the time
while I'm typing because I suck at
typing.
I'm,
I'm okay.
You know,
I'm not very good at it.
I really should practice and get better
at it.
I just have every time I get a chance to
write,
I just write.
You can turn it off,
right?
The touch bar though.
You can.
I think you could.
You can do stuff with it,
but I mean,
I don't know if you could totally turn
it off because then you turn off the
volume control.
That's where the volume control is.
Oh fuck.
Really?
The brightness,
the volume control everything.
The real problem is that fucking Siri
Button.
It's right above the delete key with my
fat.
Stupid fingers.
I touched that thing at least once a
day.
You can siri off.
She's off.
You're off bitch.
Yeah,
I don't.
I don't want Siri on my God damn laptop,
but um,
it's uh,
it just an accidental touch thing.
It's an and it's not the best keyboard.
It's a very shallow touch,
you know,
and some people like that.
It's very precise.
I'll give it that,
but I like the IBM over the,
um,
those think pants who's making those
Lenovo,
right?
Yeah.
They have a way better feel to their
keyboard,
mechanical,
the apple's operating system.
To me it's just way better.
I shouldn't say way better because
windows 10 is really good.
It's just more familiar.
Say at this point,
it was way better for a long time for
sure.
But the,
there's more options if you want to buy
a windows computer,
like you can get so many different kinds
of computers.
You can get big ones,
small ones.
You get ones with interesting keyboards,
get ones with keyboards,
they feel like,
you know,
like that,
like a Mac book or you get other ones,
like a thinkpad that it feels almost
like a mechanical keyboard.
It's got a lot more touch to it.
I know it seems stupid,
but to me that like tactile feel is a
very important part of writing.
It helps me.
It helps.
Like I like to to get in a good groove
with where my fingers are growing and
when I have actual physical keys that
stick up a little bit more and they have
a little push to them.
My fingers find their way better.
It's hard when you're on this like very
thin keyboard.
Just me.
Yeah.
I always.
I always upgraded my keyboard so I like
raised.
Her keyboards are really nice.
They make it a good one.
I have a mechanical razer keyboard for
my computer at home.
I love raised there.
The Shit.
Yeah,
my.
I got one of those razor laptops that I
decided to switch over to pc for vc vr
gaming and all that stuff and the
keyboard is mechanical one.
You'd love it.
It's,
it's like a.
almost like a typewriter.
A.
Yeah,
the razer blade pro.
Those are slick looking devices to men.
They are like literally like the like
it's a windows version of a Mac book.
Like as far as like the build quality
and everything.
Yeah.
He's got the most powerful graphics card
in it.
A desktop graphics card.
Very slick,
very slick.
They make a lot of cool shit.
They make the best gaming mice to.
They made that thing I told you about at
cs at three screen.
Laptop.
I don't think it's out for sale yet.
It was stolen.
I stole that.
That's crazy.
You know how deep you're going when you
get three screens popped open because
we're all on porn.
Three different movies going on at the
same time.
Plus you're playing a game in the
background.
Do you worry about like our devices
listening
to us at all time,
like Alexa's and Siri's and it was.
They definitely are.
Oh they are.
That's how they work.
Like,
Hey Siri,
feel like this
inevitable.
I feel like this is where it's all
going.
You know,
I think that you could fight it off if
you want and you could probably stay out
of it for a really long time,
but ultimately we are so much less
private today than we were a decade ago
and I don't think people really really
feel it yet because a lot of the people
that are like 25 today,
you guys grew up with the Internet being
like this preeminent thing like Brian
and I when we were kids there was
nothing and then all the sudden it came
about when we were in adulthood and
you're like,
whoa,
this is nuts.
Like this is all connected and it's like
the whole world is learning a whole new
style of being a person because of this
connection.
I mean it's changing everything
and kids are born into that.
Like they've had it since they were born
now for sure.
They're completely different.
People did.
I went down a rabbit hole the other day.
I went down a rabbit hole of a vegan
bloggers who are mean to other vegan
bloggers and claim that they're not even
Vegan.
It was,
it was crazy.
I was like,
I just went to the total wrong rabbit
hole that people are accusing people of
not being Vegan and people are suing
people.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Like this is Megan lawsuit.
The lawsuit's yeah.
Defamatory lawsuits.
People talking shit lawsuits.
Ooh Man.
You can go down a rabbit hole.
Right?
You know,
that's,
that's never been the case before.
Before you get into a good book.
This book is Shit Man.
I can't put it down.
It's a page turner,
but you could never like just go from
subject to subject instantaneously.
You're stupid little brain.
Just suck it up.
All the fucking motorcycle accidents and
coyote attacks and just that's,
there's never been a person like us in
terms of like the person with that kind
of access to information.
We're the first generation ever.
Like there's never been anyone before us
and we're all figuring out as we go
along.
It's like we're at the library nonstop
at the card catalog,
look,
looking at stuff,
doing research papers,
you know,
nonstop,
on everything,
nonstop on everything you know.
And then you got all your factions.
You know,
we put group up the group by white
supremacists factions.
You've got flat earth factions.
You've got,
I mean you've got giant groups of people
who chunk up together and they all like
share memes and they make fun of
everybody else.
I saw one online,
it was a flat earth guy calling all
people who believe the earth is round
globe heads and it was like.
And I was like,
what is this?
And there's a whole series of them.
There's like hundreds of them,
dude,
where people are mocking the idea that
the earth is round.
You could fuck it.
Find Anything Online,
man.
Anything,
any,
any weird group you can find them.
Have you seen it?
I typed it in Google and there's just
like the first three things or videos
like another globe had theory debunked.
Eddie Bravo.
Pissed off dude.
I fucking love those people now.
I used to get upset at them.
Now I love them.
My parents were glow peds.
Not Anymore to burn the house down
because the parents think the world is
round.
This is the meme.
It's a child standing in front with a
smile standing in front of a burning
house.
Since my parents were global heads.
Not Anymore.
So this is my point is it's the same
thing.
They're all,
it's all the same kind of mental illness
that drags you into this group Hook,
line,
and sinker.
If the group doesn't make any sense,
if it's,
you know,
vegan bloggers try and take out other
vegan bloggers or whether it's this idea
that the world is round and that the
people think the world is round,
should have their houses burnt down.
A little kid,
she'd be smiling even though it's their
parents.
I'm like,
wow,
this is so crazy.
Like I didn't,
haven't talked to him too many flat
earthers but uh,
but,
but my,
you know,
Kevin Pereira,
he,
uh,
attached a gopro camera to a weather
balloon one time or a few times.
And when it goes up to a certain point,
it's around earth.
It's the cameras show.
It can't live forever.
Is it global?
Is shill.
You don't know Shit,
man.
Eddie.
Eddie does believe in that,
right?
Like he says,
he doesn't,
he doesn't say does.
He doesn't,
he doesn't know about that one.
He keeps an open mind with everything.
That's.
Yeah.
I don't think he's actually saying maybe
is.
Maybe he's not saying that to me,
but um,
I think it's fun for people too.
I think there's that.
It's fun to think that they're right.
It's fun to the end is really,
it's fun to say you don't know and
you're right.
I don't know.
There's a,
there's a lot.
I don't know.
That's the reality.
I mean that's one thing that like if
you're talking to flat earth people and
you say,
why are you so confident that the world
is round?
Like you got a good point.
I'm not doing any experiments.
I've never really looked at the data.
I've looked at all those satellite
images though,
and I would assume that all those people
who are making maps and flying
transcontinental flights,
pilots,
people make satellites,
people have actually been to space.
I would assume that not all in cahoots,
I mean,
but I don't know might be the biggest
hoax pieces.
Could you imagine if we're really living
until.
I'm like,
what was that Jim Carrey movie the
Truman show?
Yes.
If we're really living in some bizarre
simulation and we are in a dome and
we've been just trick some fake numbers,
science and images,
I continue to think that more and more
to the point where that's my religion
where people.
That's my flatter to the.
It's getting so weird the older you get,
how much I believe in that kind of shit.
Like a simulation simulation stuff.
I think there's probably.
I think we probably have a deeper
connection that we can't measure and
that's one of the reasons why it seems
like things could be fake.
I think we have a connection that's
changing too.
I think our connection with our reality,
not just because of information and
technology that allows you to call each
other and stuff like that.
I think the information that we're
getting is allowing us to like almost
like go through the world in a different
way and things are sinking up more and
more with a lot of people.
I see.
I hear that all the time.
It sounds like total horseshit though,
but I wonder how.
I mean like what is the placebo effect,
right?
What is that
tricking your brain and to something
that's not there,
right?
Yeah.
Well you trick your body into thinking
that it took medicine and your body
heals itself.
Right?
What the fuck is that?
So there's some tricks.
Some tricks you keep.
It doesn't even happen with like
medicine.
They music and wearing certain forms
that gets you pumped up.
Music is a perfect example right there.
There's songs that,
there are songs that I hear when I'm
working out and I fucking workout
harder.
Like they give me lecture more fucking
more pep or energy and then there's a
lot of fucking movies that do that too.
Right?
Like I saw rocky when I was a little
kid.
I ran around the block,
I drank raw eggs.
I did the whole thing because I was just
like so pumped up.
That movie literally gives you energy.
I think every kid ate raw eggs when that
movie came out.
I remember doing it with my friend.
Fuck you.
And then there's glitches in the
simulation,
like,
you know,
like Deja Vu and then like,
or when you're walking down a sidewalk
and you know how you just walk people
walking next to you,
like no big thing.
But then there's that one guy where you
try to go left,
he's going left,
you're going right.
And you're just like,
why?
Why did we just sync up here?
Like,
what the fuck happened there?
Just random randomness up at all,
man.
I just made me think of it.
I just saw this article recently came
out,
others a study about why music gives you
goosebumps.
Scientists studied 10 people that claim
that they get chills when they hear
certain songs or certain things happen
and whatnot.
What does it say?
They did brain scans on them.
And what they found out is that their
auditory cortex,
which is a,
or if they have fibers in the auditory
cortex that are stronger,
I guess whatever the stronger than
people who don't feel that,
um,
which leads to a stronger emotion
reaction.
So they think that it can be used to
treat people with depression,
to get them to bring up feelings that
they might not be able to access
otherwise.
Um,
it's obviously just a new study and it's
lots of theory and whatnot.
But
like what is it?
Here's another interesting way to look
at it.
What it about a song that gets you like
that,
that gives you that energy.
And part of it is like the novelty of
hearing the song.
Not meaning that you don't want to know
what the song is about,
but you can't hear it too many times or
it loses impact.
You know,
like after awhile song becomes like flat
if you hear it too many times in a row.
I've tried to notice when it happens to
me and more often not as from a live
performance.
And I think I've,
I've,
I'm,
I'm feeling the emotion,
the person singing it has a little bit
and I like I've noticed it's more often
like a real live or there that person's
first time on TV,
one of those kinds of things.
It happens more than just like listen to
the radio or
it could probably get annoying too if
you heard it over and over and over
again.
Radio kills music.
Do you remember back in the day when you
would hear a song over and over again on
the radio and you'd be like,
what the fuck?
This song again,
it's actually get annoyed if you go to
any,
any local radio station turn on or rocks
channel,
you know you're going to hear like one
of three songs in an hour.
At least like one metallica song they
enter Sandman is going to come on once
has to come on board.
Metallica.
Yeah.
No Shit.
Right.
Boy,
that's how fucking tough gig because
those guys like know the Dj's never got
like the freedom anymore to go loose.
That just a roll up with a bunch of
records to start playing some shit that
they like.
That's what they used to do.
Right?
Correct me if I'm wrong,
but they always had program managers.
Right.
So the program manager would influence
what they would put on a little bit for
sure.
Do you remember when they would play a
record?
You could hear the record skip
sometimes,
like sometimes sometimes it would skip
though and they would have to like go
back and like we're sorry about that
ladies and gentlemen,
like some fucking dude is not paying
attention and he's off often the
restroom or something like that or
getting a cup of coffee while the songs
playing and he doesn't realize that it's
been skipping.
That happens all the time.
Back in the day.
It's a local Dj here in Los Angeles that
does that.
He plays records and he's like a real
djs.
Like one of the last guys I think.
I mean it's been a year since I've
listened to the radio,
but he used to be really cool and you
could hear the static of the record and
it was cool.
I don't,
I don't remember what channel that was.
Do you remember that Christian slater
movie or Christian slater was a volume.
He had like a pirate radio station and
they were trying to get them.
The government was chasing them.
It was very,
uh,
almost like smokey and the bandit ask.
It was so stupid the way they're chasing
them,
trying to get him because he's
broadcasting and you can't do that,
you know?
It's like he's wild and he's good luck
in and you know,
he's rebellious.
Wasn't he supposed to be in high school
too or something like that.
That was the weird.
The third year it was one of my favorite
movies growing up.
I don't know what you're talking about.
That was a great dude at the time.
It was a great movie for sure.
Well,
I'm just saying like how weird was it?
Like back then if you had like a pirate
radio station,
you a rebel and people would be out
there in the woods listening.
He like,
Hey,
if you send me out there,
you're still.
And
if you're still alive you could still
kick some ass.
Be Given these fucking corny pump them
up speeches to all the young kids.
They'd be like,
yeah,
we gotta we gotta rise against like all
the old people were retarded.
Although none of the old people made any
sense.
It was the young people that knew that
everything was wrong in the system.
Man looks like Pre-internet,
man.
That's.
Oh yeah,
dude.
You had a cordless phone though.
That's cool.
I like Christian slater.
Dig Farron.
Yeah,
that was pre internet man.
It was pretty fucking Internet.
I forget the movie I watched the other
day.
Uh,
and there was no internet and there was
no cell phones in it.
You forgot.
There's like a part of you forgets that
because there's so many scenes where the
guy's like,
I need to contact Mary.
I need to find her.
And then you're like,
why don't you just put yourself a NASA
one?
Wait,
there is no cell phones here.
Yeah.
When you need to find someone,
you had to go look for them,
like run around and yell.
People yell a lot.
Bob.
Call places.
Dude.
Italians.
I remember very clearly when I was a
kid,
especially like in like the real Italian
neighborhoods on the east coast.
People would scream out for people in
the street who just screamed dot I dot.
It would just be yelling at the top of
their lungs.
It was so crazy.
I just,
people always did that and then people
got answering machines.
That was a big one.
You remember answering machines.
I still have one in mind.
I would love to hear the messages on.
That was great.
What?
You always had to have like the best
like outgoing message.
So like your music behind it or you pick
late Saturday night live skit in the
back or.
Or like if you real creative.
Yeah,
like Tony Montana.
Mine was that Cheech and Chong period at
one time.
The one that's like,
hello,
or whatever that.
I forgot that.
Yeah,
there was always a lot of people trying
real hard to be creative.
That was like your first social media
profile.
It was and it turned into like the
instant messenger away message,
which is a status update and then it was
the grossest thing ever invented
ringback tones.
You remembered the verizon greenback?
Yeah.
Used to be called people up sometimes.
You still call people up and we'll play
a song.
Yeah,
I guess they still have it probably
Dana.
Right?
You still have king of rock.
You call other king.
Oh my favorites.
When you had to move,
you have to run DMC.
You had for a year.
I am beautiful,
Christina Aguilera,
madam.
We would just be like a normal
conversation with like adults and it's
suddenly that thing which is good
tickets.
I like some sometimes like things and I
don't like that.
I feel pressured,
not like them,
you know?
I'm like,
why?
How come I can't like that song?
It's a beautiful song.
It's,
is it,
does it too girly?
Is that what it is that.
What's going on?
A lot of prejudice.
That's how I feel with Taylor swift.
I was blaring her new song the other day
and I was at a red light and I was like,
God damn,
I got to roll up my window.
You go boy saying that shit.
Who gives a fuck?
It's weird.
You got to be scared to sing things out.
I was playing that one sia song in here
after you left one day and you came back
in like the fuck.
Like Pad Thai sauce tight.
Hashtag black twitter.
It's the hot shit.
Yeah man.
I love it.
A lot of shit that I probably shouldn't.
Like.
What's your biggest latest guiltiest
pleasure?
Um,
I like Taylor swift.
Yeah.
I love her music.
I like.
I like so your team tailor like Justin
Bieber.
I like his voice.
He's got a beautiful voice.
A couple of his songs are all right.
I'm the kid can sing his fucking ass
off.
I heard some people that kind of music
set right now because Justin timberlake
is rumored or he's going to be doing
vocals on the new foo fighters album,
but he's just doing some background.
You won't even know it's him,
but his name made it out in a blog post
or something.
That guy's not going to do.
This is timberlake.
He's a smart guy.
He's not going to do anything stupid.
If he does do that,
he's going to smash it.
He wouldn't do it if he didn't get
smashed at course.
Yeah,
we'll just smash it.
he's great.
I don't want white people shit on him.
He's like one of the best,
most talented,
handsome.
Too Tall,
too.
Pretty to rich.
He danced around too.
Good at dancing.
Don't like it.
Do not like it.
Yeah.
I don't like some handsome fellow
dances.
Real good and sings his ass off.
Fuck that.
So people are hating,
he just gets all the poise and dances.
Fucking dancer can't like dancing too
much if you're a dude,
but it's that same thing.
The same reason why you're not supposed
to like that.
I am beautiful song.
It's Goddamn beautiful song.
But you know,
people prefer you to be like,
you know,
enter Sandman don't,
which is great to get balanced in this
life.
Right.
You want a little Ozzy Osborne every now
and then you want a little shell crow.
I like a little sheryl crow.
I'm hauling notes all day.
I can't get enough of hall notes.
I can't go for that.
Got You.
No,
no.
Ken Do Hala notes.
Old School son.
Oh yeah.
If you,
if you want to hear that.
One of the best versions,
like there's a band called burden to be.
They're a local band,
will a woman singer and they covered all
the greatest hits and man,
her voice is so amazing and she just
brought like life to like those old
songs.
Like I just can't her name.
It's called bird and the bird and the
bee and it's a hall notes.
Greatest hits or something like that.
I highly recommend that.
So on spotify.
Damn son.
Yeah,
they were great.
There was a.
There was a lot of those bands.
That was like seventies music,
right?
Was that seventies?
Eighties.
This more eighties.
Remember man eater,
she comes watch out,
but she'll eat whatever you can get that
sultry side look.
Listen,
bitch.
You knew the camera was on.
Why you're looking at me sideways?
He does,
right?
That's a weird luck,
bro.
You gonna hit me.
Hey,
let's work this out.
Don't hit me.
That's like a dude is and back with his
right hand about to punch you.
Why are you looking at me like this?
Like look at me.
Look at me Bro.
That's not even.
Is extremely tight.
That's like you might.
You might be able to take my bag bro.
I left at the fashion is now the fashion
that we are dealing with right now.
It's coming back son.
Yeah.
That looks like Josh Martin on the left.
They're wearing his little leopard
shirt.
Good.
Josh Martin is like the Pinnacle of
fashion.
My Litmus test to find out what's going
on in the world.
I'm like,
are those the new yeezys?
He goes,
yeah.
I go,
Yuck.
I hate those yeezys.
I don't get it.
You still into those stupid thing,
loves them.
I have enough of them.
I will say that I need to change it up a
little bit.
This model down for three years.
One day history will not be kind to you.
You know,
you know,
all he did is he went to Korea and found
one designer and he's like,
Hey,
I want that.
Oh,
he also spent whatever.
I don't want to get into all this,
but you've spent some time working as an
intern.
I don't think you should,
uh,
deny what he's accomplished when it
comes to Mr Yeezy.
I just don't enjoy what they look like.
I don't like is tilted stage.
I just don't like what they look like.
They're comfortable as.
I bet they are.
These.
Maybe not.
If it is half of what it's about.
Yeah.
I think half of is about to have yeezy.
Well,
oh you mean the easiest half of it is my
name and my percent of 95.
90 five.
Okay.
There's more comfortable shoes out
there.
Oh,
for sure.
It's about.
It's also like a rolex.
Why would you get a rolex when you could
have a movement watch?
You know what I mean?
It's totally other watch $25,000
watch or $200.
Watch.
Exactly.
It's some sort of arm candy,
you know,
candy bracelet.
Yeah.
It's jewelry.
It's just watched jewelry like um,
like those watches that floyd mayweather
has those crazy watches that half a
million dollar watch that he had the
double arm jewelry that's not really
watch like you're not trying to just
watch costs like 150 bucks.
That's a cool watch.
What kind of Casio Casio Watch you know?
Every time I wear a watch Prince Freddy
Mercury,
little
arm bracelets I was showing.
I was pulling this up.
I just saw.
What is it?
This is the new guy that's going to play
Prince Freddy Mercury and the bio pic.
This is the guy from Mr.
robot that was show Grammy Malika.
Oh my God.
It is him.
He looks amazing.
It's great.
It looks just like him.
That Song Dragon attack the Queen Song
Dragon attack you.
That's fine.
That's my free song.
That's my song.
I want to go into freeze.
I just listened to dragon.
The TAC,
Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo Doo.
Have you made yourself to the Mac,
got into your Max,
like you're not allowed to go any
higher,
longer in the free thing.
Is that how it starts?
I don't really like you going in more
than three minutes.
Three minutes is pretty much the Max,
so I go in three minutes that I weighed
out for 10 minutes.
Then I go in for another.
The animal do it feels good.
It feels like when you come out like a
slushy,
is it little ice or something different?
They do anything.
All it does is it makes your body
produce a lot of antiinflammatories,
like a heat shock,
cold shock proteins called cytokines.
Your body produces and when it freaks
the fuck out and thinks it's going to
die because it's so cold,
oh,
just if you feel amazing,
it free.
It really feels amazing when you come
out of there,
like you feel like I'm,
uh,
Dr Rhonda Patrick explained it
scientifically when she did a podcast
about it and she was talking about the
increased.
I'm anti inflammatory markers in the
blood,
I think it was.
And the other thing was that,
um,
your norepinephrine,
I think that's how you say it,
a brain chemicals,
a spike and it's,
a lot of it is just dealing with the
fact that your body's been thrust into
this insane environment.
Like I guess I guess there's,
I mean it's like,
you know what we're talking about the
placebo effect,
right?
Like there's a way through just thinking
about something you can get your mind to
operate in a way where it fixes your
body.
Right?
And that there's sort of some,
something similar to in this respect
that like your,
your,
your brain and your thoughts for
something like a placebo effect or
something like really trying to,
uh,
really trying to figure out how you
interface with stuff.
I think,
I think I really do think that there's
more to like how we go,
like this idea that like there's a
simulation theory that you keep bringing
up.
A lot of people keep bringing up.
I think we interfaced with reality
different than we ever did before.
It's just slightly different.
Just slightly.
I think that like all the different ways
you can hack your system,
whether it's through like a cold shock
proteins from doing that or he chocked
proteins from doing a sauna or even
placebo effects,
like it might be good to get tricked.
It might be like,
that's like probably like half of the
reason why religion does a lot of people
good because if you fucking believe,
if you really believe that Jesus is real
and you read all the tenants of the
Bible and you go,
wow,
this is fucking what a great way to live
your life.
Like whoa.
You get almost like a bit of a placebo
effect and you can say,
look,
it works.
It's real,
and it's like the same way you could say
sugar pills are real,
right?
If you give a guy a placebo sugar pill,
it does nothing really,
but all of a sudden it fixes what our
aim on the ad.
It's all connected,
man.
We can do shit with our brains and we
can do shit with our bodies.
And in that Wim Hoff guys living proof
of that,
you ever pay attention to him to have
had him on a couple of times.
You've got to check out a shitty.
This guy does marathons and his
underwear.
He does.
Uh,
he runs to the top of everest in a pair
of shorts with a ice like flip flops on
his sandals on.
I'm not bullshitting.
Fuck summit's Everest.
He says it's easy.
Wow.
Yeah,
he does.
Like,
he runs barefoot in the snow.
He does marathons and all just by
controlling his breathing and
controlling his mind.
So real freak men.
Fascinating cat was like a yoga teacher
most of his life.
Went through a bunch of hardships and
really started realizing that by jumping
in cold water and controlling his
breathing,
like he,
he really sort of changed his reality
and he does it all time.
This guy goes into glacial waters so it
isn't like frostbite and like,
like physical things real like it is,
but I think your body first of all
develops tolerances for stuff and I
noticed that just from doing the Cryo
Chamber,
like if I don't do it for a few of them
out there doing yoga,
barefoot in the snow on the top of the
fucking mountain.
Is there a more bad ass photo ever taken
a look at that?
Pretty sweet.
That's amazing.
What about hyperthermia and all that
crazy guy?
Controlling body?
I think your body adapts because when
you do,
um,
if you do like cryotherapy and you've
never done it before,
the first time you do it you're like,
Holy Shit.
Like first time they do it,
they won't let you do more than a minute
and a half.
They want you to go,
oh my God,
like what is this?
And if you take some time off and you
get back in there,
like if you haven't gone in a few months
and then you go back in there,
you do feel way cold.
But if I go like three days in a row,
I can just get right in there and stand
there and it doesn't even freak me out.
It doesn't.
I just,
I'm just used to it.
I know what it is.
My body's adapted to it.
My body's accustomed to it now.
Imagine like how people live that are
living in northeast Alaska or uh,
you know,
like live in places where they hunt
seals and shed the inuits.
They don't even get frostbite,
man,
like their hands going to be out and
exposed and ridiculous cold.
They just don't.
They don't get the same sort of issues
with it that we do like their,
their bodies have adapted.
It's weird as fuck.
I think your mind can make your body do
a lot of shit it doesn't want to do and
you get your mind can do it by forcing
yourself new extreme physical conditions
like,
like a cryo chamber or like a sauna.
Sauna is amazing for you.
Apparently.
What that Rhonda,
Patrick Lady was saying that Rhonda,
Patrick,
Lady,
Dr Rhonda Patrick was saying,
was that there is a 40 percent decrease
in mortality across all causes from
everything that gets like heart attacks,
strokes,
cancer,
40 percent decrease in mortality across
everything just from doing sauna like
four times a week.
Apparently.
It's just fucking phenomenal for your
body.
Just sit there and just heat up and it
just fires your system up,
you know,
all those heat shock proteins.
They just act as an anti inflammatory.
If your body,
your joints feel better,
things move better.
So just get out of there too and you
cool off and you feel way better.
It's just,
I think there's a bunch of resources
like that that we don't take advantage
of enough and I think everybody should
be signing all the time.
I'm just traumatized from being a child
and going with my dad and seeing all
those dicks and balls.
He told you not to look shit.
You know,
I think um,
there's a lot of negative connotation
towards sauna in mma because a lot of
people think of a sauna is like a place
where people go to cut weight,
like a real painful process to cut
weight so they can make a weight class,
which is true.
They do use it for that,
but that's not the only use for the
sauna.
Like you shouldn't just be using the
sauna for that.
You should be using the sauna for
health.
We should use it all the time I think.
I think it's a gigantic important step
in like a body maintenance.
It's like a bunch of shit you have to do
for body maintenance.
I think that's one.
Has there been any news updates on
there?
John Jones situation and like I haven't
heard enough and that's so
disappointing.
So makes me sad.
Right.
Abandoned sites on this one.
Yeah,
that's right.
You called the Dick Pills.
I would just like to state for the
record,
Brian
banned completely called the Dick built
thing.
You,
if I paraphrase,
you were like,
let me say he parties.
He does coke.
Uh,
he,
you know,
he probably took some Dick Pills.
I was like,
what?
Jesus Christ,
it made so much sense.
It was like how it was there right along
the whole time.
I just remember the FDA dot Gov had
breakdowns of certain,
like Rhino,
a dick pills at gas stations and a lot
of them had steroid type things in them
and he's so crazy.
He was taking that stuff that is still
taking them.
Well now I bet he would.
I mean now that I always like fuck it,
I'll just take everything.
You could get addicted to them.
I was addicted to him for awhile.
I don't know why.
I don't think he's addicted to it.
The new thing that he tested positive
for has nothing to do with that.
They said the new thing that he tested
positive for his steroid,
that the only test for in urine and
according to jail Sunnen it's like a
very,
it's not a very common steroid and it's
actually kind of old school.
It's like something that used to do a
long time ago.
So he,
it's his thought was that if somebody is
getting them to do that,
that if that's not a tainted supplement,
if someone's getting them to do that,
that person knows their shit.
Like that's some sneaky steroids now.
Yeah.
And he said it's usually combined with
other things since.
So unfortunate man.
I don't know if it's true,
right?
He could've got sabotaged.
What's he saying?
Is he saying no one's saying anything?
There's no official statement.
I don't think like [inaudible] there's,
I think they're trying to test other,
other samples.
They tested a blood sample and then they
released the results of the blood
sample.
They always do a blood and a urine.
The blood sample was negative,
but the blood sample didn't test for
that stuff.
So I don't,
you know,
you could speculate all day long.
I'm sure as the facts come in,
we'll get a better understanding of it.
But it would be the most disappointing
thing ever if someone's spiked his shit,
it almost be less disappointing if he
took something and got caught that it
would be if somebody
did him.
That's why I'm saying it like he knows
his past.
It just seems ridiculous to think that
he would even try,
even if it's old school or stuff,
they barely tasted like.
It seems like why would he even risk
that?
Because you already went through that.
Right?
But being a cage fighter is a ridiculous
way to make a living and people who are
cage fighters,
especially like elite level,
like a guy like Jon Jones,
he's that guy has like probably a belief
in himself that you and I will never
understand and completely impulsive and
like what he decides.
So he's why he's a wild motherfucker.
That's why it's so good.
Because he's smart and he's wild.
Like he'll take.
He's like legitimately wild.
He's wild chances.
Like I always talk about like when he
fought shogun for the tile,
when he fought shogun for the title,
he opened up the fight with a flying
knee.
There was the first thing he did
fighting a legend,
finding a UFC light heavyweight
champion.
I mean he was crazy talented and still
is right?
And he's only 30,
but he's a wild man and wild men
sometimes.
Do Shit that they don't even know why
they're,
why they're doing it.
They're just doing it,
you know?
And if you're a guy that's that powerful
as the garlic Jon Jones,
like,
try controlling him.
Good luck.
Good luck telling him he can't go out.
Good luck telling him what he's gotTa do
you know?
It's one of the things about him in the
past is that he hasn't trained hard for
fights and they were way harder fights
and they should've been probably because
he really wasn't in shape and everyone
around him kind of knew it,
but it was,
he was that good that he could fight
world class title challengers and beat
them in five round fights without really
training.
Like that's how God damn good.
That guy.
So you and I,
we don't know how his brain even works.
So who knows what the fuck happened?
I hope he didn't do something.
But then again that means that one of
two things happened.
Either he took a tainted supplement,
which is after awhile almost becomes a
joke.
Like to keep people keep saying that he
stopped taking supplements or even worse
at someone spiked him.
Yeah.
The spiking thing because it seemed like
a pretty crazy.
Yeah,
that would be crazy.
You could do that to somebody though for
sure.
I mean if somebody is around someone
with nefarious intentions or someone's
around someone who's resentful and
you're in some sort of pro fight camp
and someone just decides to fuck this
guy and just dumped some stuff on your
chicken steroid cream in your hand.
Cream.
I think there's things they could do to
get it into your system.
You probably wouldn't even know what it,
the tests that came up positive I guess
is the one that happened,
right?
It was after the way in.
Yes.
It's a urine test and tested at anytime
before that.
Um,
I'm sure he was there.
They were tested multiple times in camp.
Um,
it wouldn't have probably come out.
Not necessarily because it's really
like,
well if you know,
I don't know,
like what kind of time period they
tested them in and I don't know what
kind of half life this stuff has because
uh,
apparently Chael Sonnen was telling
Brendan Schaub that it gets out of your
system quite quick and that's one of the
things that guys like about it
apparently.
So you could do it.
It,
it gets out of your system really quick.
You'd have to find out like how much
time do they usually have in between
visits by Usada and what are the odds
they're going to get busted?
Like how much,
how many times during camp or they're
willing to roll the dice,
see if they have a 24 or 48 hour acting
steroid.
How many times can you roll the dice?
You sought a visited three times.
You got to roll the dice this week.
Roll it.
Come on when I have a hard workout
Thursday.
Fuck it.
Let's roll the dice.
You roll the dice 27 hours.
No,
you saw 28.
You wake up and the all night sweat and
30 hours.
No.
You know,
if they come,
you've,
you know,
if they come you're fucking career's
over and they take away millions of
dollars,
40 hours your pen.
Oh No.
You saw the,
the next day you saw it,
you start thinking 52 hours.
How many hours is that?
How many has it been?
Pretty.
Hey,
for 9:50,
50 1:50.
Two,
three hours.
Three hours.
It's got to be gone.
Right?
It's got all begun and you give them
that pice.
Just wondering whether it's in and I'm
sure there's stuff that you can take
that supposedly washes it out fast or
like any kind of drug tests you know,
mean like we'd test.
I remember,
I think it was like cranberry juice or
something.
You just constantly drained.
There's certain diuretics for sure.
Certain diuretics can mask steroids.
It's one of the reasons why they're
illegal.
I'm looking at this article that came
out in about an hour ago.
It looks like on a bloody elbow at it.
That's not like any update of news or
anything really.
It's a ped expert who's known,
uh,
in the track and field world as known
for supplying performance,
enhancing drugs to them.
His name is Angel Hernandez,
also known as memo.
Not that that matters a whole lot,
but if anybody knows him a what
an angel.
Heredia Heredia Hernandez,
but Angel Heredia.
Is that the same guy that used to train
manny Pacquiao or know who the fuck did?
There was a guy that was a really
popular.
Goddammit.
I know I got his name wrong,
but a strength and conditioning.
You're saying that the test that they do
texts tests for six different.
Our particular metabolites,
one of those can last up to seven weeks
and a dennis skipped down to here.
He says that one of those metabolites
can look like the same structure as the
Toronto ball and it may or may not.
It doesn't mean that it's not Toronto
Bar,
whatever,
but it could be from a bad supplement
that he took during the training period
that lasted in a system and ended up
looking like it.
Ooh,
interesting.
But that's.
Listen to this quote,
listen to this quote.
If he would have been using way before,
then he eventually would have been
positive on the 21 days,
testing before the fight,
but he was negative.
Then he came out positive.
Frankly,
the testing itself,
it lacks credibility for a lot of
reasons.
A,
we could go on and on,
but and I could be very specific in
terms of chemistry,
but I don't want to mislead the people
that listen.
It's just the fact that they are
detecting six different metabolites in
one of them stays there longer than
seven weeks,
but the most intriguing part is that
some of those metabolites are not really
confirmed that they are actually coming
from that to how do you say that,
to rentable,
to ball structure.
All right,
but you sorta who's doing this,
they know what the fuck they're doing
and they're not.
They're not going to come out with a
result unless they're super,
super sure that that's what they're
tested positive for.
I don't know if this is
skype right?
He's just sort of speculating.
I would imagine.
I don't know if he.
If he wasn't there either.
Tell you.
I talked to Jeff Novitsky offstage,
I mean off mic on my.
I talked to him around the arena.
He's,
he's about as honest as it comes when it
comes to like handling these situations
with these athletes.
They're catching people and the people
they're catching,
we're using,
there's,
you know,
the way they're doing it is very
thorough.
The way they're handling it is very
thorough and there hasn't been anybody
with a credible story that came forth
that didn't have something in their
system that they weren't supposed to
have in their system.
We haven't had a case of that yet as far
as I know.
I think almost all cases have been
either 10 tainted supplements or someone
getting caught,
whether it's taking a diuretic or
something,
getting caught,
taking a steroid.
There's a lot going on like that.
And he's got,
you know,
they have a team of people that are just
constantly checking people that might be
cheating.
I guess you have to also say it's where
there's smoke,
there's fire.
How many fighters?
You never have a steroid in him.
You know,
there's a few,
you know,
like Bj Penn,
uh,
I'm sure there's a,
you know,
I used to think it would be John Fitch
within John Fitch tested positive he
was,
but he was getting older and he was
fighting and world series of fighting
wasn't in the UFC anymore and you know,
he might've been dealing with some
serious injuries.
Need to pay his bills for fighting.
Like I don't begrudge anybody,
especially when they're not even in the
UFC and the testing that they do in a
lot of these organizations.
It's like there's a lot of,
uh,
there's a lot of organizations that have
guys that are pretty much openly using.
And what they do is they have these guys
fight on Indian reservations or fighting
weird states that have an athletic
commission that doesn't really adhere to
the rules or it doesn't have to.
It doesn't restrict.
But what,
especially the Indian reservation thing,
native American reservations,
they took whatever the fuck they want.
Man,
there are country inside our country,
but you sata,
they look up your ass man.
They look up your ass.
They come get you.
And they wake you up,
hey man,
hey,
how you doing?
Hey,
we're going to have to look at your deck
and I'm going to watch pis come out of
your deck and it's going to go in this
cup.
And then you can go back to sleep.
[inaudible].
It's a,
it's no joke.
And uh,
to see a guy like John was just
spectacular,
just spectacular comeback,
fight,
you know,
I mean,
like a Phoenix,
he rises from the ashes.
He gave this really classy post fight
speech.
He won by just overwhelming devastation.
I mean,
it was a beautiful combination with the
left high kick and then a series of
shots.
Daniel goes down.
He just beats him unconscious in a
spectacular performance.
And then to find out that it's tainted
by some fucking gross steroid.
They were,
they were sneaking in.
It's either that or again,
the other one,
which is almost equally grows that
somebody gave it to them.
Like somebody gave him some,
hey man,
hey champ.
Have some,
have this gatorade,
champ,
you know,
hey champ,
I've got your gatorade champ crack,
you know,
and they're very assessable.
These fighters,
you know,
they're going to,
they're just going to the gyms you go to
a lot of times and if you're not
fighting John,
he's a great guy.
Yeah.
He's a great guy,
great guy.
And people love them.
Um,
I think that,
uh,
we don't know,
you know,
just makes me sad.
It makes me sad.
But one day,
you know,
when Dale they'll have it eradicated,
but by then I think there's gonna be
some new methods.
I think they're going to have genetic
methods.
That's the next one.
They're pretty,
not pretty close,
but they're,
they're pretty close to being able to
alter embryos and to be able to change
like genes in people maybe even shut off
dangerous jeans,
like genes for Alzheimer's and
different,
different diseases that people have.
They might be able to literally create,
create the,
the tools to edit that in the embryonic
stage to something called crispr and
that's one of the things that they're
using to,
to,
to alter genes.
It's like Star C,
R I s,
p,
r,
I think it is.
Did you see the video of someone used it
to make like neon green beer or
something like that?
They use crispr to make neon green beer.
Would they use like.
So they did something to the wheat.
Awesome.
They made a new color chocolate the
first time in like a hundred years.
They made a new chocolate.
Oh,
we're fucking around with nature.
That's why Hurricane Irma was going to
eat Florida.
They also recently took the West Nile
virus and pumped it into rats and it
killed the cancer,
which is crazy.
So you're taking one crazy thing and
killing another crazy thing with West
Nile virus cures cancer in mice or
whatever,
but yeah,
that's.
That's the thing.
It's like there's a lot of shit that we.
That animals can't even touch or they
die.
This biohacker.
What does it say again?
Sorry.
Wants to spur a genetic engineering
revolution with glowing beer.
That seems healthy.
I'm worried about aspartame.
Engineered yeast.
Imagine how bad your pee smells like.
Think about how bad your pee smells when
you drink or you eat asparagus.
Cutting edge genetic engineering
technique.
Crispr.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's how they did it.
That's insane.
He sells the kits to.
Apparently that is so crazy.
You can buy a kit to genetically
engineer through Crispr your wheat to
glow.
It's pretty bad ass.
That's insane.
It's got to be bad for.
It's totally for good.
How I'm waiting for one of these fucking
problems that we have to turn us into
superheroes because that was what we
always saw in the comic books.
Right?
Every time there was a nuclear spill,
dude came out of it with x Ray Vision.
Right.
But the government also immediately
found the guy and took him and hit him
and did tests on him so the public
wouldn't be scared.
Tried to borrow pride to.
Most of the time they were afraid it
already happened.
Autism,
now they're like some of the best,
uh,
like navy coders and.
Oh yeah.
Well there's,
there's without a doubt some super
genius.
People with autism.
And then there's people that are on that
spectrum,
you know,
autism and also asperger's and a lot of
different disorders that allows them to
like focus on stuff with laser,
like precision.
They just,
their brains work different.
There's a lot of thought to that.
That's like the next style of person
that like we're so connected to our
devices and to the Internet and to do
this we're going to lose our interaction
with each other and lose our emotions
and that it might manifest itself
through a series of like weird errors
like a disease or a disorder and that
disordered becomes favorable and that
favorable disorder of just not really
getting attached to things.
Just focus on your work like a drone,
like a,
some sort of crazy robot number
crunching robot.
Like it's a 100 percent possible that if
you.
We know there are some people like that,
right?
So if there are some people that are
just super genius coders,
they're just zone out and can code like
crazy and they're kind of on the
spectrum.
If there's one of those that could be a
thousand thousand,
that could be a million.
If there's a million,
they could start breeding and making a
bunch of other ones like that and maybe
it's something to pass on and Eugene's
maybe pass on more than in our genes and
we know.
Next thing you know you got robot people
like we slowly but surely integrate with
our chips and fucking different qualcomm
chips in your brain.
Your phone is now part of your body
robot.
People with abilities to call each other
and connect online and like what if
that's like nature's trying to engineer
our humanness out of us.
Slowly morphing change.
It may get more compatible to staying in
front of computer screens.
Constantly crunching numbers.
People's hands start growing different
because they went to a holding cell
phones their whole life.
Their eyes get farther apart,
like chance the rapper.
You know what fascinates me when people
have autistic kids,
then the kids show massive improvement
from a change of diet or from cannabis.
Cannabis oil for for a lot of kids is a
massive improvement.
Stop their seizures.
Makes them start interacting with other
kids.
Better wonder if that is what I mean.
I don't think they know like a specific
cause for autism or any of the spectrum
disorders right now.
I mean,
I always just blamed cell phones and
Wifi.
I've also heard it could be right.
I've also heard gut bacteria be blamed
for a bunch of them.
Wow.
Extensure's.
Yeah.
They were saying that um,
a lack of probiotics and the Diet poor
gut bacteria can be blamed for certain
issues and disorders that some people
have found neurons in the gut.
Right.
If those two things are true,
that makes sense.
Well,
if your gut bacteria is essentially like
a,
like a community,
right?
You have like a community of flora
inside your stomach and the more bad
stuff you put in there and then it also
like other people would be way more
susceptible than some,
you know,
like,
just like today there's people that can
eat things that maybe have mild
allergies and then there's someone like
you or I that we could eat the exact
same thing and have no issue with it
whatsoever.
That's got to be the same with gut
flora.
It's got to be the same with.
I mean,
we're so biologically variable,
but if just imagine if that's just a
step in a long process of peep.
I mean like you look at like a super
genius autistic people.
We as far as we know,
I mean they might've existed hundreds of
years ago but we don't know of them.
Right?
We're just guessing.
This is a fairly recent thing.
What if it becomes something even
different than 100 years from now?
What if it's these,
these people that know how to read each
other's minds and only they can do it
and they can all read each other's
minds.
They can probably read our minds.
We can never read theirs and they just
read.
They're just talking to each other and
we're like,
Hey,
what are you talking about?
What are you guys talking about?
Like,
we're going to be left behind like our
stupid genes.
We're going to be left behind and these
people without.
What if like war just stops because
autistic people just have no desire to
go to war.
Like not just rather sit around here and
code,
you know,
or whatever the next stage is.
Like if if autism or asperger's or any
of these things are a new thing,
I don't know if they are,
but if they are a new thing,
just imagine what another new thing
could be that takes it to another place
and the next level.
People that don't keep their vr helmets
on all the time that you've lived in the
railroad.
What's wrong with you?
Well,
you gotta think man,
if evolution is true,
and I'm assuming it is.
We used to be super primitive,
right?
We used to be some sort of primitive
primate thing and then there was a bunch
of different versions of us and we
branched out and we were the most
successful and we made it to today.
So that means we changed.
So why would we assume we're done?
That's crazy.
We're getting more input now than ever
before and we're assuming we're done.
We're not even the same people from the
19 fifties.
We're not,
we're just,
we're,
we're totally different.
I wonder if our brains are going to
start using more because we are more or
less or less,
but I mean we're pretty much like,
you know,
we're using our brains way more than we
were 20 years ago,
20 years ago.
Instead of like researching and reading
and reading,
pretty much we're just probably sitting
there looking at colors,
you know,
or something
to who would have been way easier back
then to be a con man.
Nobody could do any research on you.
Yeah.
Well I was reading on the town and all
that.
Right?
Well,
raising a Buddhist monastery,
Eddie had the greatest fucking story
about that.
Eddie Bravo was taking karate or Kung Fu
from this dude that said he had to go to
China to learn,
uh,
from,
you know,
some Kung Fu masters and Eddie was like
so proud.
It's like,
wow,
my instructors,
like one of the greatest churches in the
world is going to go to China,
learn from some Kung Fu master.
And then he saw him like a supermarket
or some shit.
The dude's car was like parked in front
of China.
He's like,
that can't be him.
He got in the car,
he drove off like,
what the fuck?
I thought that deal was in China.
He just totally lied.
Not only did he lie,
but he was so stupid.
He stayed around the neighborhood.
Wow.
There you go.
On vacation for that.
He just lied to.
The students was pretending he was off
gathering knowledge from the masters.
There was a lot of those guys,
man that had like fake karate classes.
They'd like fake martial arts schools.
They were teaching like nonsense and
they would have this crazy background on
the wall,
you know,
seven time undefeated,
marine corps,
bare knuckle,
no holds bar champion.
They would make up a bunch of shit.
There's a lot of those dudes,
man.
My favorite youtube videos.
Oh my God.
So many of them are just so many of
them.
It's like the religious people like,
like you know,
if people falling on the ground are
getting thrown by the room,
by the pet,
the pastor and stuff.
It's the same kind of shit.
Yeah.
And a lot of ways.
But that's like the other side of the
placebo effect.
Right?
It's like there's the other side,
like those people,
when that guy got does that thing and
they go flying through the air and they
start their body starts,
do you think they feel something like
what do you think is going on?
Are they just totally faking it?
I think it's done on this guy.
I think it's all dumb people.
I think it's low watt brains that just
they're easy to trick and to believe in
anything.
I mean look at look at half the road.
Yeah,
for sure.
That's a possibility,
but I want to know like are they doing
it?
Are they conscious of what they're
doing?
Like are they willfully giving into this
because they want the guy to like them
and like he comes up to you.
I was like,
oh.
Or are they really feeling it?
I mean,
are they convincing the.
Is it a placebo effect?
Are they convincing themselves?
I think so.
You think so?
Yeah.
I think.
I think the like dumb people can really
do a lot that we can't even fathom.
Like we were saying,
if you really believe that there is a
know makeup,
but it doesn't even have to be Jesus or
are gods,
I don't want to offend anybody,
but if you really,
if somebody really believed that Odin
had carved his path in eternity and
that,
uh,
his,
his destiny was chosen for him by the
cards and he would go forth with that
kind of confidence.
Like if you really believed that Odin
has carved a path for you to destiny and
you really believe that,
like that's got to be a powerful weapon.
It's just having that belief.
There's something to that.
Whether it's real or not,
it might become real because you think
it's real.
Like the placebo effect is just one
little,
one little sliver of this weird puzzle
of managing the mind and managing the
way you interface with reality,
with people,
with,
with life itself,
with different choices that you make.
I don't think we understand it 100
percent.
I don't.
I think we just assume that like
physical acts or like all that's going
on,
you know,
like he picked up that box.
He moved it over there,
like physical acts are all that's going
on.
I don't think so,
man.
I think there's like there's some,
some weird connection that we're all
sharing that's getting closer and
closer.
It's getting weirder and weirder.
People Getting Shittier and nicer at the
same time it's happening.
There's a boiling point of.
I think people are way nicer than they
ever were before.
You know what we use as an example?
The Bro Hug.
People didn't bro Hug back in the day.
They shook hands when we were talking
about that new,
a standup show on showtime.
I'm dying up here and uh,
one of the things Bill Burns said,
he goes,
they got the handshake wrong.
He was talking about it last night.
He's like,
he goes,
they hugged,
nobody.
Nobody hugged back then he goes,
they would do like a low five or
something like that.
And he's like,
I was like,
you're right.
You're right.
They didn't hug like that.
They still,
they did like,
like the knuckle thing back them though
maybe been for sure it was still like a
high five,
high five.
It's silly.
It's fun.
I like high fiving people.
I always Miss People's high fives that I
feel like an idiot.
Like I'm always
high.
Five to me is like fun,
like high fives,
fun,
like a handshake.
You could just be just cordial and
friendly,
but this has got some fun to it.
When's the last time you did a low five?
What's that?
Man?
I can't even remember because you've got
to get a low five back.
This problem with a low five.
High fives.
Egalitarian.
Everyone's equal.
It's just high five.
Low five.
We have to decide.
Well,
who was hitting who?
You hit me and my head.
You know,
you're gonna.
Hit me first and then I'm gonna hit you
back.
How's this work?
Okay,
you go first.
Ready,
go.
Slap.
Nobody does that anymore.
I'll slap.
I haven't done that yet up because
people figured out we don't have to do
this.
We can just do this is better.
What's up?
Like I,
I feel happy when I get people high
fives.
I'm a knuckle guy,
man.
Tim.
Except too much pink guy.
Too much.
Too Much?
Yeah.
You gotta wash your phone man.
I was reading this thing about cell
phones.
They were saying the dirty than half the
toilets of the world.
Oh yeah.
Because he never wash your phone.
You touch everything.
You like.
God Wash your hands.
We're just touching her ass.
Me.
Oh,
you pick up your phone and you're
checking your twitter,
your mugs and all kinds of weird fucking
biomes.
All of your screen.
I saw,
you know,
like there's but whites where they had
like the little container where you pull
the wipes out.
Like those things,
like you reuse them.
Like if you to think about,
around the thing where you're grabbing
it.
Like I need another one.
I need another one.
I got some on my finger.
I think you're right.
For sure that happens.
Yeah,
for sure.
That happens if you mess up.
Yeah,
I just used the packs.
I don't even use the boxing
and you got to be careful with those
things too because you don't want to get
antibacterial wipes.
Like you don't want to use antibacterial
stuff on your body unless it's like
natural stuff like that.
Um,
I used to do Jujitsu with this dude who
got ringworm and after he got ringworm
he started putting antibacterial soap
all over his body,
but that killed all of his,
his natural skin flora and then he got
it everywhere.
It was
great.
How much did he use [inaudible]?
I use that,
the anti bacterial soap that like
hardcore stuff.
It looks amber and say this stuff,
they extract the insects DNA on Jurassic
Park.
Um,
that stuff like,
it stinks.
It smells like chemicals on it.
Yeah.
That's hand antibacterial soap.
And a lot of people like that would get
like ringworm or something like that.
They would use that on their whole body.
But the problem with that stuff is it
kills everything.
It kills all the stuff that's fighting
off the ringworm to kills everything.
Just nukes the territory.
And I use tea tree for all that shit is
the shit.
I just hate the smell.
Eucalyptus lived soil.
There's a company called defense soap.
Yeah.
I talk about them all the time.
11,
not a sponsor,
but the guy's awesome.
And his stuff is amazing for that.
Like keeping healthy skin floor.
We just have to think of our bodies,
whether it's your gut flora,
your skin floor,
all that stuff.
You got to think of your body as an
ecosystem,
you know,
[inaudible]
defense,
so it's really great.
I use that all the time.
But do you ever use it for like a
Jujitsu?
Is that what it's made for?
It's made for.
Well,
he made it for grappling,
but
it's great for just skin.
It just good for your skin.
It's not chemical because they use it
like as my soap.
Okay,
cool.
I didn't know if I was going to like for
you,
so I'll bet for you at all.
It's good for your skin.
That's the thing about it.
It's like it's not damaging the healthy
stuff.
There's no poisons.
It's not like antibacterial soaps are.
A lot of times it's like really heavy
chemicals that are just stripping away
everything.
You know?
Bacteria lives on our skin in the lot of
it is good.
Apparently that's staff's all over you
all the time.
Like when people get an infection and
it's a staph infection,
what it is is you get an open sore and
then your body through whatever,
for whatever reason,
can't fight off that staff that's
already there.
There's now getting into your
bloodstream and he'd get infected and it
swells up and gets nasty,
and then there's that immersive staff,
that staff that they get at hospitals
because people have been taken
antibiotics for so long.
They have medication resistant staph and
scares the fuck out of people.
You have to be on like ivy drugs for
weeks.
Sometimes people are just wrecked,
wrecked by.
It happens to a lot of fighters,
man.
It's like the silent killer of fight
careers is Murcia with that whole Kevin
Randleman.
Yeah.
We don't know if that was mercy or just
untreated staff.
I don't know if it was Murcia or just
regular staff work guy.
Yeah.
Kevin had a.
He had a bad.
I've seen a lot of guys have it bad.
I've seen guys with holes.
It looks like somebody stabbed him in
the leg and it was just.
The body was,
I think it's called an NEC reifying or
something like that.
Yeah.
When your neck.
That's something word.
What is the word necrophilia?
No.
Yeah,
but it's um,
there's a word that when your skin
starts becoming dead in certain areas
because of a lot of it's like widow
bites.
We'll do that.
I'm a brown recluse bites.
Staph infection.
We'll do that too.
Yeah.
There's a lot of widows.
I forget the term,
but it's some something Niekro does
something to your skin.
Just there's a lot of those fucking
creepy little bugs that'll do that too,
man.
Ever seen someone like what it looks
like when someone gets bitten by a brown
recluse.
No.
Fuck Dude.
If you get beaten,
if you don't take care of it,
like really quickly,
it can go super bad.
Like those things eat through your body.
We sleep in so many hotels and shit.
Have you ever had bed bugs because
that's like.
I haven't,
but you could definitely get it.
I feel like I get bug bites every time.
Holes.
That's all from a brown recluse bite.
Yeah.
Fuck.
Are those in La or California?
No.
Um,
yeah.
They have some of them in California,
but I think they're more in the Midwest,
but they definitely have him here.
Yeah,
look at that.
mostly around there.
So it's mostly,
it looks like some Texas and a lot of
the south.
It's fucking scary ass bug man.
That's a scary 10 sharks found in the
home's basement pool.
What some guy in New York had 10 sharks
that were in a 15 foot above ground pool
in his basement.
Three of them were dead when they found
them.
Seven.
We're still alive.
People crazy because he's out of his
fucking mind.
Wow.
Well,
he might have.
Okay.
They were two feet to four feet long.
Those are little sharks.
He might've been.
I'm trying to do some sort of a deal to
put a fish tank in somebody's house and
he acquired these sharks for it or he's
a nutty dude and he wanted to keep
sharks and sharks.
But here's the thing,
like I knew people that had sharks in
there,
fish tanks,
like everyone's all gung Ho to save the
sharks.
Now that was not the case 10,
15 years ago when people had swimming
pools or not swimming pools.
Um,
fish tanks like crazy fish tanks.
Sometimes people would have like little
sharks.
He used to have crazy fish.
Yeah.
I used to have a paranas.
Allegedly this may or may not be true
for Amazon.
Exactly illegal.
I might've found something at a friend's
house in bowling green one time.
Yeah,
they're boring.
Boring until it's go time.
And then you're like,
Whoa,
I want to get like a,
like a,
an octopus whatsoever.
Like things that glow in that,
like the black lights,
a jellyfish jellyfish.
I want to get like a jelly fish
aquarium.
Like you can I guess,
get that with the light.
So it just looks like you have a ghost
in your corner of your house.
They die easy though,
unfortunately.
Yeah.
I was talking to a scientist about it.
She was explaining that,
um,
they have like a,
Mandalay bay has this.
You ever seen the thing where they have
the Jelly Ooh,
tank of jellyfish that you could buy
little tiny jellyfish.
The accord is,
but you can buy basically.
And so,
um,
but she was explaining that they have to
constantly,
like shuffle them in.
They'll take out the dead ones,
putting the new ones and they breed them
there.
Wow.
Do you ever see the one they have at
Mandalay bay?
Dude,
it's the shit.
It's like a circular one and it lights
up different colors.
Dude is beautiful.
Look at these guys like Jelly fish.
They look too much like twins to be
boyfriends.
Right?
Right.
So creepy.
Their boyfriends and they were that
close to each other.
That's,
that's a weird thing to have laying
around.
What do they eat?
Uh,
I think just algae.
Oh,
so is this like a go fund me or some
shit?
Yeah.
I think the one they had at Mandalay bay
was bad ass because it was this big like
acrylic cylinder and they were all
swimming around it and they changed the
colors.
Like I think that'd be cool to have that
they're alive,
man.
I mean it's,
they're alive.
But is that it?
Yeah,
I,
I didn't.
I don't remember them having.
Wow,
that's the one in Mandalay bay.
I'm probably conflating it with one from
one of the aquariums that I've been to,
but fuck,
that's beautiful.
How pretty they are.
Can you imagine doing mushrooms and just
looking at that shit.
They're so pretty,
but it seems Kinda fucked to have them
trapped in a tube just swimming around.
They can't go anywhere.
Like isn't part of the magic of being a
jellyfish is the fact that you're a
jelly fish in the ocean and you just are
constantly moving through the ocean or
have we decided that the jelly fishes to
primitive for it to truly experience the
majesty of the ocean and fuck him
getting the tube and gamblers just gonna
Stare at you.
I mean that's essentially what we
decided.
Feed feed,
feed.
They feed at least once a day is.
I went to the same baby brine shrimp,
so like sea monkeys.
Eight.
See My god,
they're so weird looking.
You know what's interesting?
If we found,
oh,
you have to have like a separate tank
for all that stuff.
It looks like you have two tanks.
What is that?
That's the baby brine shrimp.
Oh,
weird.
That's how bizarre.
Oh,
they're in this little sheets.
Snap into strain and you have to put it
in a base there and squeeze it in there
or something.
Whoa.
Weird.
The size and number of jellies would
determine how much to feed.
Oh,
you have to be like really specific.
Fuck feet and get some fat,
Jelly Fish.
Die Dude.
Or they're going to get out into their
toilets and then.
Oh,
look how they feed them.
Man.
That's crazy.
It's cool.
They just squirt it out there.
I wonder if they came back in.
What was the out?
Now I'm back in.
I'll figure it out.
I'll just,
I'll do the right thing.
I'll measure it.
I'm sure a dead jellyfish looks just the
same.
You know,
it's just not.
They're not moving enough though.
You want to move and man,
look,
look who's pouring in there?
Looking at them all.
Heating.
That's crazy.
They're,
they're actually reacting.
Here's the thing,
like,
they're so primitive.
We probably don't feel that bad when
they die.
Right?
Like,
if a goldfish dies,
you're like,
Oh,
poor little dude.
Because eyeballs,
eyeballs,
uh,
their faces.
Right?
Like people I've heard people say don't
eat anything with a face,
but they usually don't eat oysters.
Those people gotta eat oysters.
I love oysters until you have bad
oysters.
Had some bad ways.
There's the other day I definitely have
before.
That's the worst.
Yeah,
I mean there's a possibility,
right?
You're eating something wrong.
Yeah.
Did you know,
there's so many different kinds of
oysters.
Like I never knew that there was like
tons of different kinds of oysters.
Yeah.
I don't know a lot about them,
but uh,
I do,
you know,
if you go to a place they give you a
variety,
you get like a dozen year,
three of each.
Like,
Whoa,
look at these Kuma motos and there's a
lot in the Pacific northwest.
I know people like around the Seattle
area,
they actually
go out and get them and get clams and
stuff like that.
There's a certain kind that you're not
supposed to eat anymore because of some
kind of pollution levels or something
like that.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yeah,
they go clamming and the Pacific
northwest is pretty.
They get big ass clams to man.
They go digging them right on the shore.
They just like bring a bucket and just
dig into the sand pot those fuckers out.
That's pretty bad ass.
And go find some clams.
Santa Barbara has the biggest oyster
farm,
like interact,
like it's,
it's huge.
And it's usually like go out and have
these underground cages and they lift
them up and.
Oh Wow.
And you just pick them and eat them and
that's good enough.
Hm.
Wonder how much they're affected by
pollution.
Think it's a lot.
What's up?
Aren't they not like fully used for
pollution,
but don't they clean the like a shit out
of the ground?
Like the clean the water.
I thought that's what they're.
They're kinda like the ocean filters.
Hmm.
Well that's what lobsters are,
right?
Lobsters and crabs.
They eat all the dead shit.
That's A.
isn't it interesting that they're so God
damn delicious.
All they eat is rotten shit all the
time.
It's weird.
Lobsters are so delicious.
Like sometimes you forget,
sometimes you forget and you get a,
like a Maine lobster when you dip them
in butter and you're like,
good God this is fucking delicious.
Check this out.
Here's a timelapse of oysters filtering
water.
Whoa.
It's super dirty water here and then a
couple hours go by.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Did they just poop them out though?
The oysters bitch.
Just throw a bunch of sand in that way.
See what the fuck goes down.
Yeah.
It seems like their filter in the
waters.
It's crazy.
There sense.
Look,
nature has a plan for all.
It's a little weird things and I bet
they have all sorts of.
I mean you think about that.
We need plants for oxygen,
right?
Plants actually create oxygen and we
create carbon dioxide and plants live
off carbon dioxide.
It's weird how there's all these like
little relationships that all these
different beings have like back and
forth all over,
all over nature.
So many of them in so somebody weird
parasites and symbiotic relationships
that animals have with each other to
fucking.
It's a dome,
Bro.
Flat to dome,
so all simulation.
I'm blown away.
I just got a dehumidifier the other day
yesterday and how much water you can
pull out of your air like I've already.
It's a 70 gallon drum or a tank and I've
already emptied it three times 70,
70 pint.
70 pint,
sorry.
Not counting 70 70 pint a gallon of
milk.
I know.
Biggest 77 got swimming pools the fuck
are you doing in your house man?
But it's a pretty huge bucket of water
and just like four that's just pulled
out of my house.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
No,
it's just like from your body notes from
any aridity I see.
I've been,
we've been using our air conditioning so
much lately that mine started leaking
everywhere if it.
So it's making the house wet you.
It's making my floors fucked.
So uh,
yeah.
So I'm trying to suck all the water out
of it.
Everything.
So it just pulls it from the air and
humidity and stuff.
That's weird because La is pretty dry.
Yeah.
But not lately.
It's been pretty shitty.
Well it's not shitty.
We need watermelon,
you know,
if we,
we,
we barely got away with what we got last
winter,
you know,
they're kind of brought everything back
to pretty normal.
But like,
like lake to hone to hone ranch still
half full of water.
That's what my,
uh,
from my personal experience,
what I can see about how weird the
drought was,
there was a lake that we used to drop
people out of helicopters into a fear
factor.
And it went away.
Like the lake didn't exist anymore.
There was no lake.
All the fish died.
All of them.
It was,
there were huge fish in that lake.
Like big,
large mouth bass.
There were all over the place.
Man.
People would go from miles around to go
fish.
They're dead still dead today.
Just nothing there.
Wow.
So little bit of water now.
A little bit of water,
like maybe like last time I was there
I'd have to go see it again to get a
good read on it.
But uh,
the last time I talked to somebody who
was there,
it was like half full,
you know,
it'd be interesting,
which means it's really shallow.
If it gets rained and it comes back to
life,
if how long it would take for the first
fish to find its way there due to
probably be a million years or a
psychologist accidentally drops one in.
The thing about these.
What does that cost tech?
No,
that's like a steak.
So Lik is take in 2017.
Looks pretty good.
It's back.
That's nice.
Yeah.
That's another place where we used to
draw people out of helicopters that was
talking about to Holland Lake though.
And this is what came up and said,
well that's pretty close.
It's on the way.
But uh,
yeah,
that,
that place has giant striped bass.
I saw the stuntman on fear factor.
They would go fishing like in between
stents that had like a lunch break and
these guys caught these like in like 20
minutes caught these giant ass striped
bass.
That place is awesome.
But that was half gone,
you know.
So you got to see it with our own eyes,
like places like drying up and just
because it caught it and it turned
around because the weather changed
doesn't mean it can't happen instead of
three,
four years,
five,
six years.
How about 30 years?
Thirty years of no rain.
Go Fuck Yourself.
That's.
That can happen.
I think it's going to be the opposite.
I think just how bad of a rain that we
had last year and I think this winter I
think we're just going to get pounded I
think and like all the Burbank mountains
that with all the fires,
I think we're going to get flooded now
from all the mud,
mudslides that that's going to cause.
Because I think this end of the road
shit's just continuing to go on.
See?
I don't think it really is the end of
the world.
It's not even the end of us.
It's just that what we thought was
permanent was very fragile and that Fox
of their head,
but you just got to go into it knowing
that you can't think that those hills
are going to stay up to slide.
Those houses are going to slide,
you know,
it's just like there's some fucking
people that built their houses like
this,
like hanging off the side of a cliff
with like spikes into the side of the
hill.
You've seen those houses.
There's a lot of those,
right?
Like on Laurel,
you look,
look at that house.
You Go,
where's that one going to go?
That's going to slide down here.
Remember they shut down Laurel Canyon
like a few months back because one of
the porches,
back porch,
like 9,000
fucking pounds slid down the hill,
all concrete and shit.
And you know that's gonna Happen to the
comedy store at one point.
Like every time you're around behind it,
every time it rains,
I'm scared to fuck to be that asked for
that movie heat.
But that house is preposterous.
Stupid.
I'd hate to live in that.
Was that Robert Deniro movie heat.
Wow.
What a crazy view they must have though.
There's a lot of those houses,
man.
Look at that.
That is.
You have to be such an optimist.
Everything's gonna be all right.
Like look at that fucking house.
Look at that thing up on giant ass metal
poles.
Seems like such a pattern.
Every night you hear some crazy homeless
man sawing at your pole.
Oh my God.
You looked out.
Get the fuck away from there,
man.
Man saw.
Nah,
man,
I saw you go to bed.
Check out this ad for him from 1969.
None of those are safest buildings as
far as landslides and earth tremors are
concerned.
Why none of those exist anymore.
Oh,
let me read this.
The cliff dwellings amongst the safest
of all buildings as far as landslides
and earth tremors are concerned,
are supported by steel girders.
Planted deep in the ground.
Anchor to heavy iron bells.
Far below the surface.
Actually I gives me kind of excited.
I liked that.
The engineer the shit out of it like
that.
That's actually.
I like when someone solves what seems
like.
All right,
I'm,
I'm on board now.
I want us stilt house with metal bells.
So it's like your house is supported by
Kettlebells motherfucker.
Yeah.
Until,
I don't know.
They probably didn't have like a five
point.
Oh earthquake.
They were probably like at least a good
for like the strongest earthquakes at
three point four,
but it'd be good for all earthquakes.
You don't know shit,
Bro.
I bet none of these houses exist
anymore.
It was one in the upper right hand
corner.
That's like one of my favorite pictures
is scroll up past this spaceship
spaceship house.
I love that.
That house is the shit.
I don't know who owns that house with.
That is the fucking coolest house of all
time.
I think it was just sold recently.
I would never want to live there.
That seems like the perfect house for
you though.
It's too freaky.
I would go deep.
I need to stay calm.
Like if I lived in a spaceship,
I don't trust myself.
I was just,
uh,
I just got to go to Ron White's house
recently.
It's a nice house.
Yeah.
You Know Ron's story.
What happened?
Yeah.
Who went out of town,
came back and he.
There was a leak on the first floor and
it flooded well on the top floor,
the third floor rather.
And it flooded down to the second and
the first four filling all of them up
with water.
That's unfortunate.
And he just had it finished now.
Fuck.
Yeah.
But it's cool.
He has a recording studio in there and
like a bar.
It's like a pimp house.
Sure it is.
Ron White's that shit.
Bad Ass.
I love that guy.
He was just in Austin doing a benefit
show with Eliza and Leah and they raised
like $250,000
in just one show.
Yeah.
That's awesome man.
That's awesome.
I heard about that.
Yeah.
Ron White's fucking fantastic.
I love that man.
He's beautiful.
He's an animal.
You know.
You were you ever hear of a APP called
next door or next door?
Next door.
It's one of the greatest things ever.
It's a,
it's like Reddit for your neighborhood.
Oh No.
So it's pretty much you log in and you
have to live in this neighborhood or you
can't get in.
It's pretty much kind of thing.
And it's like,
it's cool because there's little things
like,
hey,
I got this,
you know,
dresser,
if anyone wants it or you know,
things like that.
But it's also like,
Hey,
I saw a black guy the other day and the
neighbor psycho,
Tony Hinchcliffe bit.
Which one?
The mass text bit.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's like that.
Don't say anymore.
Yeah.
I don't want to give away a bit,
but it's the most addicting thing ever
in.
It's very helpful,
like if you have a lost pet or a cat or
a.
But it's one of my favorite things to
read now I just go home.
I'm giddy about it.
Like,
oh,
what's going on?
But we do have an interface that allows
you to communicate with people,
like straight to your head.
How,
how quickly do you think you'd adopt it?
How quickly do you think you'd try it?
I guess if you could turn it off,
I would try it pretty close.
Right?
Why do you trust the government?
Man?
Times,
man.
Yeah.
I'm worried about my car right now being
hacked,
you know,
it's too little,
too much.
Like I don't even have a emergency brake
anymore.
I have a button that says I know.
I'm like,
no,
I want to pull it up.
Emergency.
I don't want to push it.
I like old cars for that.
Yeah.
Like I like a car that has the fucking
brakes,
baby.
Yeah.
Right,
right.
Those are the ones you want to with the
button on the top.
You don't want to stomp,
break.
That's for assholes because you can't
even control it.
You've got to like stomp it and pull it
back up and like you don't have like a.
You can.
You can actually control the outbreak
with the lever a little bit.
You can get yourself to go sideways with
that thing.
My car has a bug lot of it probably.
Yeah,
they probably don't have it filled.
My car is a bug though.
If like you plug in your iphone before
like too early and you don't hit the
button that says,
you know,
agree to like the maps or whatever.
Yeah.
It's like,
hey,
it's okay if that goes away.
And then like if you have your air
conditioning on and other things,
you can't turn them off.
So like the other day my stereo was like
on full blast.
My air conditioning is on full blast and
I was trying to turn it all off while
driving and it couldn't.
This was your Honda?
Yeah,
yeah,
it's got apple home or air or car car,
police,
car.
But if you disconnected your phone when
it stopped,
that's how I did it.
But I.
At first I couldn't figure out what was
going on.
I've never heard of that before.
Yeah,
it's kind of happened.
Yeah.
That's a dope car though.
I like it,
man.
It's cool.
It's a,
it's a technological tour.
De Force.
I could hook up androids or it has like
android play on it.
Also new.
Most of them didn't have it,
which is kind of fucked.
I couldn't believe that they were
getting away with going with apple
carplay only because there's a lot of
people that would buy like Chevy's and
GM cars,
like cadillacs in particular,
they have that apple carplay.
Porsches have that apple carplay.
I like it though the texting.
Definitely,
I never text while driving anymore
because now I just tell Siri to,
hey,
text joe,
what's up?
Oh,
you can do that with both hands on the
wheel.
It's awesome.
Yeah.
Yeah,
I like it.
I'm a fan.
I'm a fan of those,
uh,
the,
some of the new Japanese cars to a man
that,
some of that technology that's coming
over with [inaudible].
They got some incredible shit.
They just put out this new lexus,
the Lexus Lc.
Five hundred CV could find Lexus lc 500
in atomic silver.
They're making future cars like,
you know,
remember when you were a kid and he
thought about cars in the future.
Like what they would look like.
This car looks like a future car GC.
The first flying car.
I saw it yesterday on the news.
Uh,
I don't know if it was.
I think it was real.
Yeah.
I don't know if it's real,
but it looks like.
I'm sure that will be something.
Look at that thing.
We'll look at that car.
Beautiful.
That's a spaceship.
Look at that thing.
I mean that looks like some Sylvester
stallone movie from Nineteen Ninety
Eight.
You know the year 20,
60,
20.
Yeah.
Especially in atomic silver.
There's something about that silver
color that looks that's a rendering,
but that's a ridiculous looking car.
Cars are so sexy nowadays.
I really liked them.
Well they can do so much now.
They break for you.
They recognize objects in the side.
They give you warnings.
Yeah.
Mine has the lane departure,
so like if I'm texting and not paying
attention and I go out of my lane,
it pushes you back in.
Or if somebody stops in front of you,
slams on the brakes.
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
Which that kind of freaks me out because
what if there isn't something there and
it just malfunctions and slammed on my
brakes,
know?
Well it probably can happen.
I mean anything that's automated can
fuck up.
Just like a person fucks up.
Is this the flying car?
It's called the what?
The lilium jet jet.
We believe in a world in which everyone
can fly anywhere.
Anytime.
Oh Jesus.
Anywhere.
Like what about Hawaii Bitch without a
terrible joke.
But you're going to fly across the
country and I don't trust that guy.
Looks a little wacky.
So he's on adderall.
Sell me a dream.
The vision becomes a reality.
Now this is like the beginning of a
science fiction movie.
Fuck you doing.
Are you bringing in an organism from
space?
So this is real.
Is it real?
This is the first test flight.
It says it's probably slow as fuck.
Like a balloon just floats through the
air.
It might the onion.
Why do I.
It doesn't seem real to questionable.
Three hundred kilometers an hour.
So what did we decide that is somewhere
around 150,
150.
It's all about
that guy takes too much ecstasy.
I don't trust him.
It's got that look in his eyes.
You know that?
Look when a guy's done a lot of extra,
see it doesn't look like he's just
shooting party.
He doesn't look real.
That's shadows.
The thing looks today,
Jamie Goodman the comments.
Look in the comments,
not a man dreams.
Some bitch.
Fairly fake.
Half the comment section.
Oh goddammit,
you sons of bitches.
But does it squeeze cheese?
Recent article about,
uh,
what they were calling a Russian troll
farm that they have a troll farm,
like make a business out of trolling.
I met someone recently that his,
he worked at a meme factory.
What?
I didn't really ask a lot more questions
about that because I just assumed it was
like someone working for that fuck jerry
account where there's like four or five
guys that all work together to just talk
about memes all day.
But he literally was working downtown
somewhere in his job description was
whatever at a meme.
Factories.
That's kind of hilarious.
Yeah.
Cool job.
You know,
by the way,
mad props to some people that actually
use the internet.
Like when the guy that writes for
Wendy's twitter,
I don't know if you've been following.
This is some of the funniest shit ever.
Whoever Bravo,
you were the king of twitter.
But like people like talking shit on
Wendy's,
he'll come back with like some of the
best comic timing ever.
Wendy's owned a twitter troll so hard.
They deactivated their account.
So that's the first one.
Our beef is a
right is your beef is frozen.
We all know it.
Y'All know we laugh at your slogan
fresh,
never frozen,
right?
Like you're really a joke.
Wendy says,
sorry to hear you think that,
but you're wrong.
We've only ever used fresh beef since we
were founded in 1969.
The other guy says,
so you deliver it bra on a hot truck
says,
where do you store cold things that
aren't frozen?
Wow,
y'all should give up.
Mcdonald's got you guys beat with the
dope ass breakfast,
and then he said,
Wendy says you don't have to bring them
into us just because you forgot
refrigerators existed for a second and
it do this for a couple of strong.
That's really strong because they didn't
even lose their temper.
Like that's kind of funny.
Oh,
and they handled that really well.
Wendy's has been doing this for about a
year now.
Just nonstop.
Wilson.
I don't like to get burgers on the road.
I don't like to get fast food,
but if I do,
that's the one I go to Wendy's all day
unless there's an in and out nearby and
I've got extra time,
extra time.
Wendy's,
we'll give it to you in a shocking they
quick amount of time,
like how is that even possible?
It's actually hot.
Like what do you just anticipating
selling a certain amount of double
cheeseburgers.
Whitney's Burbank is also that when the
future stores,
they're testing where you walk in and
you order off this huge ipad like wall
and and then your food comes and it's
like you don't have to even talk to
anybody anymore.
Yeah.
There's a lot of those now,
right?
Yeah.
Well the other thing Wendy's does is
they let you be a total fucking slob in
order.
A three,
a triple cheeseburger.
They have it like right there on the
menu.
It doesn't even look crazy.
Like when I go to in and out,
I'll order a three by three.
I feel like an asshole,
but with Wendy's it's like it's right
there in and out.
I'm asking for some shit that doesn't
even exist on their menu supposedly.
That looks good.
Look at that.
Dave's hot and juicy.
A three quarter triple you motherfucker.
Whenever I eat one of those,
I'm like,
this is such a preposterous sandwich.
At Fat Burger.
They have all the pictures on the wall
of everyone that's finished the giant
fucking trip.
Right.
So great.
It's such a big thing.
It's as big as people's heads.
It's giant.
It's like speaking a giant.
Did you see that fucking guy that had a
bladder stone that was the size of an
ostrich egg and he get it.
He had to get it removed from his body
was sued.
That is the craziest thing I've seen in
my life.
Like this guy had a rock inside of his
body that his own body made look at the
size of that thing,
so we get the guy having it in his hand.
So what does that mean?
That all right.
What is in your question?
That's a good question.
I think that's what it is,
but she tasted it.
No God.
The hey is.
What do you think it would taste like?
Salt it salt?
Yeah.
Why is that any weirder than licking
salt that came out of the ground?
Take that you grind it up and put it
under state.
Nobody cares.
I would lick my own stone.
Somebody else's.
Find out ct scans of the man's abdomen
also revealed another much smaller stone
in the man's left ureter,
which is the tube that carries the urine
from the kidneys to the bladder
according to the report which is
published today,
blah,
blah.
The doctors treated them and noted that
he had invasive bladder cancer more than
a decade before he developed the stones.
Well,
wonder how long it took them to make
these stones.
Woo.
Imagine if they just keep making them.
You have to make up fucking.
They have to build a door into
his body where they could reach in once
a month and pull out an ostrich egg
sized rock.
Like how often does it,
one of those things cook up inside your
body.
It's got a years,
Huh?
That's an issue with not that in
particular with kidney stones or an
issue with a fight or sometimes a cut,
a lot of weight.
It becomes a,
uh,
unwanted side effect,
real bad to men.
Kidney stones are brutal.
A lot of guys have canceled flights
because of kidney stones and actually,
no,
I've never had them.
I'm Matt Metro and actually had them
before,
uh,
his fate or fight and they had to cancel
the first time they were supposed to
meet because kidney stones,
super competent,
Matzoh heavyweight,
which is even weirder because
heavyweights don't have to drive
themselves out,
but somehow some people just genetically
are predisposed to getting them and then
somebody gets him.
That's when you tap it out.
She gets it like maybe every six months
she has god.
That's horrible.
Yeah.
Fuck man.
I wonder if it's like a diet thing.
I think it's a little bit of that.
I think it's also just some people just
know get 'em all the time.
It's also like the Diet thing,
just so not fair.
Some people could just scarf,
you know,
they could just chow down pizza and
check.
They do it right in front of everybody
and they look like Tb.
You know,
they never gained any with his clay.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Well don't eat pizza every day.
He works out a lot though.
It just does work out a lot,
a lot.
Go to my good amounts of good in front
of the other night.
My arm.
He's like,
what are you doing to take something
else?
Like I know I'm not.
I go to the gym three times a week.
Tony Heart.
How many times a week you think Tony's
going to the gym?
He's worked out with me before.
I think he's just.
It's worked out in the same areas.
Mistake on the treadmill versus kettle
bells.
Did some weights,
lifted some weights once.
He's pretty ripped.
He lifts weights.
I think he does a little weight lifting.
He's shockingly ripped.
Find to have a contest.
She.
Jamie,
I think Jamie works out way more than
Tony.
Tony has.
Tony incident might be like.
I'll take you up on your context.
Young Jamie might have to get another
one.
Yeah.
We still have to figure out what we're
going to do with this other lady.
Goes already.
Went Back to New York.
We got nowhere with that.
I fucking.
Yeah,
we barely did.
They wanted to wrap it up.
We're going to finish this.
What is it?
Well,
we came to one idea which was a a
contest gene Sigora burt,
Ari and me that for the for 30 days of
October.
No booze and you have to do 15 yoga
classes.
We all agreed on that one.
15 hot yoga classes,
90 minute classes,
but no breaks.
Right?
Or something like no breaks.
Alright.
He wants to take breaks like a bitch.
I was going to lose anyway.
I feel like that's one of the reasons
why we say,
well,
what about a broad.
I'm going to take a photo to go with pig
pig.
I'm a Jew.
Jews need to pick.
Everybody said that I go right here.
That didn't make sense.
He peed twice during the show.
He pulls his dick out and pisses into a
Kombucha jar.
What?
He's he doing that shit a lot.
A lot of this is wild man.
He lives in the jungle for months.
He lived with a,
you know,
like natives and shit.
Yeah,
he's out there in the forest.
He's crazy.
But um,
so he's basically backing out.
He's like a kid drew a kid,
started living out of suitcase.
I'm like,
bitch,
you were in Asia for four months,
living out of a backpack,
sleeping in hostels.
Now all of a sudden you're back.
You got to taste the good life.
Didn't he also bet already walking
around naked?
Why is he walking around naked?
They went to the desert last night.
Oh,
they do mushrooms.
Yeah.
So ours just wandering around.
Jesus Christ.
That makes sense.
There's a place next to me,
has a new kind of yoga used to try out.
I want to try it out.
Uh,
it's outdoors.
It's a baby goat yoga and it's pretty
much you do all this yoga and then
there's this baby goats that will climb
on you while you're doing it and run
around and stuff like that.
Oh,
this is supposed to like the baby goats.
Like,
feel good.
It make love kids.
Yeah.
And it's hilarious right next to my
house I needed to do that is fucking
hilarious.
So they let these goats,
they were literally shit in your face
while you're down there.
They don't do that.
So these people are doing their yoga
while they're doing yoga.
They have to do it around these goats.
Goats just climbing up.
The guy's probably like,
I don't know why I decided to up for
this to go.
So fucking incredible balance,
man.
Like from the box,
like right out of snatch.
They can climb a tree.
Now you should have baby goats.
I think.
Why not?
I had a friend who had goats.
I had a friend who got goats because he
has a big piece of land in Topanga.
And uh,
the goats ate everything.
They don't stop eating,
man.
They don't just eat the hay either.
They're like,
fuck your head.
And they just start wandering through.
You look at the goat climate treatment.
How does that happen to fucking palm
tree?
They just can do.
That's the crazy.
How's it going?
And get down.
They calm down,
dude.
Yes.
I am so amazed by baby goats.
I want one so bad.
Yeah.
These things are crazy.
Did it fall out here?
Didn't receive videos that eagles coming
in.
Super Nice.
But that's different.
They grabbed me.
They definitely fall.
They have fallen in the past.
They definitely fall and animals.
Uh,
sometimes like bears in particular,
if you see a bear,
I'm eating a mountain goat.
A lot of times it's because the mountain
gold fell like bears most of the time or
not catching mountain goats.
That's one of the reasons why they have
adapted to live in these crazy
environments is because predators can't
get to them.
They're like,
this is what they've done.
They figured out a way to exist.
Yeah.
Like how keep that thing there,
man,
hold on Jesus Christ.
I want to see what the fuck happens,
but look at what it's doing.
Like trying to figure out how to turn
around.
I mean it is on the side of a cliff and
also it knows not to do anything stupid
and it's not freaking out.
It's amazing.
It's almost like the brains don't have
the ability to look at that.
Oh my God.
I'm freaking out.
Like the way those things can catch
themselves and the way I can walk on the
side.
Oh Christ.
Oh my God.
And they're not scared of heights at all
at all.
Like they don't have that in them.
He's young too.
That one looks young.
You know?
I think that what you saw like that slip
right there,
that could definitely slipped to it's
death.
It definitely could.
It must happen every now and then.
Somebody.
I attached a Gopro to an eagle recently
and they live streamed it on periscope
and it was one of the most fascinating
things.
Just seeing an eagle fly around and look
like,
look to the right and see like a little
dot moves and so then we'll get closer
and then.
And it was a cool camera view,
so I don't know if it's on youtube now,
but very interesting to watch.
That is crazy that you can do that now,
right?
To a camera on an eagle and see things
from his perspective.
Did you ever see that photo?
A series of photos where a mountain lion
tried to kill a goat and they both fell
to their death?
Yeah.
A mountain.
A mountain goat.
Was it a mountain goat or was it a sheep
made a mountain sheep.
I think it was a big horn sheep.
It was like,
yeah,
it was like a mountain lion and the big
horn sheep and they were both splattered
on the fucking highway.
It's,
uh,
it's amazing though.
It's an amazing series of images.
Like,
I mean,
I'm not a cruel person.
This is not me being cruel,
but I think there's something beautiful
about that and this is what I think is
beautiful about that.
Go to like fullscreen with that thing.
Full series.
Just go it.
I printed that one picture that you had
up.
Sorry.
Go look at that.
I mean,
they're both gone.
They're both next to a cliff.
And the only way this happens,
right?
You see the horn off to the left that
says other horn off.
No,
I blew off.
I mean,
they probably felt a long way.
Go to the series now.
That's a,
it's what's crazy about it.
It represents how hard that life is.
Like,
look,
it's just blood's pouring out of his
head sets nuts.
That is nuts,
man.
Where the,
where the horn blew off.
Holy Shit.
God Damn Dude.
Look at that mountain lion tree to,
to,
to tweak.
It's got a mouthful of furrowed brow.
Never let go.
That is so powerful.
Oh,
that is so powerful.
It probably had it in its mouth.
As they went down.
They both went down together.
Dude,
this is a daddy is a goddamn powerful
series of images.
Look at that backup and see the height
of that cliff.
Holy Dick.
Banga surprise.
He didn't land on his feet.
He probably held on that goat the entire
way down.
That's a fucking murderer.
It fell from somewhere up there.
Jesus.
How high that is
found on a closed road near glacier
national park.
Fuck,
dude.
We got to get those images for the
studio.
We have to see if those are for sale.
Find out if those are for sale.
I have a poster printer.
You just send them to me.
I'll print them out for you.
I think you're supposed to buy those.
Right?
Those are like,
um,
there's something powerful about it
that's not like just a picture of a kid
with a balloon.
Right?
You know something about that.
Like somebody had to be there to get
that picture.
This.
Does she get some money?
Printers are pretty amazing nowadays.
I,
I got this poster printer for like $200,
$300 and it,
it prints like pretty decent size
posters and so like you can just go,
go,
hey,
you know,
I've always wanted a werewolf poster and
you just printed out and it's like go
into the store,
boom.
You have it framed a big.
Um,
I'd probably say like maybe 31 by 20 or
something.
I don't know.
I've been seeing a lot of stuff that
special effects guys like Rick Baker are
doing with three d printing now.
They're making all these masks and heads
and shit with three d printing.
Imagine if you could just make something
in a computer and then go over to the
three d printer and print that bitch out
for some things.
That's perfect.
Like I just lost like a little battery
cover to one of my remotes the other day
and I bet I if I had a three d printer,
I could find the model of the battery
cover and just print it out or make it
in a fun.
That's amazing,
right?
Yeah.
When you really think that,
how much of that is going to be like the
future of objects,
you know,
the future of things,
like how much less shit would you have
to sell people if you could just sell
them.
Oh whoa.
I would print that out.
Is that Rick Baker's Popeye makerbot
three d printer I believe.
Oh my God.
That's awesome.
That's amazing arts.
Then he paints it.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Look at that one right above it.
That's so cool.
Wow.
Go back to that other one that you just
had with that whole.
The whole series of them.
There's the Benito Doterra Werewolf A.
Yeah.
Sort of.
Pretty close to it in the middle.
God Damn.
That's amazing.
That'd be fun to paint.
Yeah,
right.
Once it's three d printed out.
Right?
These guys have so many tools at their
disposal now,
but I wonder how much of that is going
to be lost like all the special effects
makeup stuff in the transition to cgi
because it seems like it's just
inevitable that CGI keeps getting better
and better and better arguments for
having a mix of this and using practical
effects and I saw a clip of that gay
American Werewolf actually moving in the
back while they were testing it out.
It looks obviously fake as shit,
but you can't.
We know what to look for now in that
fake stuff and it really is catching us
off guard all the time.
Just like when I saw that video right
away were like fake,
fake,
and even when it looks good,
10 years later you look back at
something and you're like,
God,
that looks horrible.
White Dude.
I played King Kong,
the original King Kong for my kids a
couple of years back and they were
laughing.
They were so scared at first and I was
telling him,
no,
I'm not showing you anything scary.
I'm like,
this is going to be really funny.
It's so silly.
It doesn't seem real at all.
And they were like,
no,
that's the monster.
I go,
yeah,
that's the monster.
And you know,
because they're little kids,
they overlap.
Fell down and they're being so silly.
It was really funny.
I really wished that nuke,
that King Kong Island was better.
I hated that movie.
Swamp man.
How many times can tell a stupid story,
so racist story.
Anyway,
King Kong surrounded by black chicks
never cares.
One white chick shows up.
He loses his fucking mind.
He's climbing buildings.
Bring them into that.
He breaks out of chains.
It's so stupid.
Look how big he is.
Not that big.
That's pretty big.
They changed a bunch of times.
Different versions.
They have a graph that shows all the
sizes from all the past.
Maybe he said him and Godzilla.
Well,
the Japanese movie was a big one.
They made him like 500 feet tall or
something crazy.
So I think he was supposed to be like 50
feet tall.
And the first one is that over there.
King Kong escapes.
Nineteen 67.
That's the one.
18 foot,
12 foot tall in the 1933 one.
Wow.
That's it.
Yeah,
that's what I was saying that he looks
so small compared to like.
Wow.
And then he was 12 feet tall.
The son of Kong.
Oh,
that's the little one.
Yeah.
King Kong lives.
That was my fear.
I saw that in theaters.
So he was pretty God damn big.
He was a thousand feet tall.
King Kong Godzilla.
Godzilla was gonna fuck him up period.
Like how much bigger is.
How has that even not even close the new
Godzilla.
Super Fuck them up.
The new Godzilla has goddamn terrifying.
Seems to be thinking you can't make a
good one of these.
That was a which years?
Skull island one is the newer one.
The newer one.
I mean you can only make so many of
these God damn things.
You know,
after awhile it's like,
let me guess know the girl is going to
make you.
She's going to be fun.
It's going to have a few close calls.
I'm going to be real excited when she go
with me.
Okay.
This is the girl that blonde lady going
to be okay.
He won't.
He's stomping on black chicks left and
right.
Just stop it his way through the village
stepping on black dudes.
Just that white girl.
He's just so enthralled buyer.
It's the most racist movie of all time.
Like the first time King Kong sees a
white chick,
he loses his shit.
I went
down a rabbit hole the other day
watching that one gorilla that you know
Robin Williams used to hang out with all
the time.
What's that grill at Koko.
Have you ever watched any of his coke?
I love that.
It's pretty amazing.
They're very smart man.
Very smart.
Yeah.
I mean they're not like people smart,
but they're like you.
You understand that they're not.
This is not like a gopher or groundhog
or something like.
They're on a completely different level
than most other mammals besides us.
Coco recently got some new kittens and
it's watching.
It's amazing watching him play with the
kittens.
I think it's a girl,
right?
Yeah,
her.
Sorry.
As gendered Coco Bro.
That's just one of those animals.
You just think it's a guy.
You know,
you look at it,
it's like.
It's like how I look at dogs,
I considered them guys and cats girls
for some reason.
Yeah,
because she could smash your fucking
head and anytime she wants.
So you almost how strong the thing must
be.
Yet she's so gentle.
They're vegetarians to their sweeties.
Grills are big sweeties for the most
part.
What's really kind of nuts,
man is a chimpanzee.
How smart they are.
She's twerking.
Twerking,
let's see that.
Hey,
can I get on that
strong torques by the way?
They will love it.
She has been working on our host skills.
She's not just,
this is not like our first time doing
that.
She's developed those fast twitch
muscles.
You know,
we could really torque to girls who
twerk and you go,
Whoa,
you really do know how to do this.
You know,
you ever seen like a little kid tried to
do a Yo Yo.
They don't quite get.
It doesn't come back all the way.
Like Shit,
you know,
you try to teach them now you got to
like go down and then go up when they,
they never get it.
That's the same thing with like a a
amateur torquer girl doesn't really know
how to work.
They don't have that kind of pop and
bounce that that girl did.
That girl has done a lot of things.
She probably regrets.
She's probably been hammered more than
once doing that.
It's probably gone but to.
But with other girls.
I love butter,
but yeah,
but to.
But yeah,
it's been a lot
of the box that comes in and asks man,
in the last couple of years I've never
asked her why.
How can't even imagine.
I was a tit guy for so long,
like assets.
I've really enjoy the whole woman by the
way.
Yeah.
That's like the male feminist approach,
asshole.
He just treat them as a whole woman.
Not think of it as like a tit guy.
Guy Get girls are like,
I'm not a dick girl.
You know I liked the mouth.
I like to eat my box and shut their
mouth and a A.
I saw that.
I looked up.
I had to find the black China naked
photos.
Boobs are back.
They're back near amazing.
They
went away.
When the fuck did go away,
see,
this is just like people run out of shit
to talk about this,
what it is.
It's like half the things that we
discussed in this podcast,
like what,
what are they doing?
We're just shooting the Shit folks
concrete.
They're printing it.
Congratulations on that.
That,
that.
A New York Times a retraction that you
pretty much cause that was pretty
beautiful watching that go down.
I mean it was a guy who wrote it and it
was printed in the New York Times,
you know,
I mean,
it wasn't the New York Times,
but it's an individual's choice and
maybe an editor's choice to embellish
the reality of what happened.
They said that Connor's,
it was about the boxing match.
They said that his face was covered in
blood,
completely covered in blood and that he
was rescued before he fell through the
ropes.
Neither one of those things are true.
Just not true.
His face wasn't bloody at all.
I mean,
he had a little bit of a swelling under
his left eye.
Um,
he was definitely getting punched in the
face and I definitely agree with the
stoppage of the fight.
He was exhausted and he was a fallen all
over the place,
but it was more that floyd was just
teeing off on him and he wasn't firing
back.
There was no blood and he didn't.
He wasn't gonna fall through the ropes.
He might've went down,
might've went down at one point in the
fight.
I mean,
if,
if floyd kept punching him,
that might be actually a smart move for
them to catch 10 seconds,
you know,
do a standing eight count,
get up at the counter or you know,
do go down to a knee rather get up at
the count of Eight,
you know,
they brush your gloves off,
you get a second or two there,
then you go back in.
Maybe that had been enough for him to
get through the round,
you know,
because he was for sure having a real
hard time recovering.
But with the New York Times where it was
just not true,
like what it was was just as juicy what
it was.
His 40 year old boxer comes out of
retirement and schools,
the number one most popular MMA fighter
in the world in a boxing match,
proving what a lot of experts already
knew that a specialist someone is the
greatest specialists of all time when it
comes to boxing.
I mean it's pretty arguable.
Floyd's in like the two or three people
that you could argue like the greatest
of all time.
In my opinion,
floyd is the number one,
but he beat conor mcgregor in a way that
you would expect a real specialist to
beat someone who's just pretty good at
it.
He was masterful.
Fucking awesome to watch and what Connor
said afterwards,
hilarious too.
I turned them into a Mexican.
He fought like a Mexican because that's
what people love about.
Mexican fighters at Mexican fighters are
known for coming straight at you.
Like Mexican fighters aren't dancers.
They're not dancing around and you know,
doing the Ali shuffle,
they're like Julio Cesar Chavez.
If moving forward,
you know,
they're like Marco Antonio Berrera.
They're moving forward Mexican boxers or
like some of the proudest,
most rugged warriors ever.
That's how floyd fought.
Fought really?
Did fight like a super technical
aggressive brawling style.
He tired connor out that beat his ass
too.
Beautiful Man.
Beautiful for boxing.
Beautiful for,
um,
for the overall art of fighting because
we need to see these things.
I think this thing that we're all
participating in eat fans of of MMA,
practitioners of MMA,
this thing that we're all participating
in is trying to figure out what style is
the very best style for fighting period.
And then we found along the way that it
varies.
It varies on the individual styles.
Make fights,
and then sometimes one guy can beat
another guy,
but that guy can beat someone who could
beat him.
And it gets real weird.
Like mma.
Math is one of the squirrel,
earliest fucking predictors of who's
going to win a fight ever.
But we're finding out like what?
What's fucking real?
Like when you got all the belief in
yourself in the world,
when you've got knockout power,
when you really believe you could beat
the greatest boxer of all time,
what happens?
Oh,
you get fucked up.
Okay,
that's good.
It's good to learn.
It's good to learn that even though he
lands it lands a few shots,
makes it a real interesting contest.
Good to learn that the best specialists
of all time is that for a reason.
This isn't bullshit.
This is floyd mayweather.
He's 49 and now now he's 50 and no,
I mean that's.
That's good for combat sports.
It's good for everybody.
That's what's so stupid about this whole
boxing versus mma feud.
It's so dumb.
It gets everybody excited about fights
and this inter competition thing between
a an MMA fighter coming over to boxing.
That's even more fun because then it
gets like everything excited on both
sides and I think it's gotten a lot of
people super excited about Canelo
Alvarez and triple g,
which is next weekend.
People are super pumped up about that
fight,
particularly because we're just past
this.
Connor Floyd Mayweather fight.
Floyd mayweather has his way with connor
just puts on a display and now we're
going to get to see instead of the
master versus a guy who really wasn't on
his level.
Now we're going to get to say to guys in
their prime,
at the top of the food chain,
to the top three,
top four pound for pound fighters in the
world,
and they're going to go at it so it's
good for everybody.
They just don't.
They.
These guys are so old school.
They understand social media in a sense.
They know they can use it to promote
fights.
They don't know that it's changed the
whole community and that instead of like
having some stupid rivalry with this
other like sport mma,
instead of having that just accept each
other,
accept each other and talk highly of the
best examples in both sports and
everybody will be fine.
I mean that's what you're seeing with
this conor mcgregor floyd mayweather
fight.
That's where you're to see with the
triple g Canelo Alvarez fight.
You don't have to be one or the other
and the boxing.
People don't have to not like MMA.
I love boxing and I work in MMA.
I love boxing.
I watch all the big fights.
I'm always gonna.
It's fascinating.
It's awesome.
It's nice to know who the real
specialists are.
You know,
when it comes to that,
I love kickboxing.
Big Fan of that too.
I like to know a lot.
I love Jujitsu.
I want to know.
I wonder how good are the best guys?
What would happen?
The best guy in the UFC fought the best
guy in Jujitsu in a straight up Jujitsu
match.
I want to see,
you know,
those are.
Those things are interesting.
I went to see a box or go to the UFC and
see how it's going to happen eventually.
You know what I mean?
We had James,
Tony,
of course,
but James was way past his prime and it
didn't even look like he trained for
that fight.
I think James just took a payday.
If I had a gas,
you know,
and randy just hit them with a low ankle
pick.
Took them down.
I think maybe hit a low single.
I forget what it was,
but he went way low,
but either way there's not a chance in
hell that James Tony was ever going to
stop randy coture from taking them down.
It's just not going to happen.
He would have to catch them.
Absolutely perfect.
Coming in for the very first punch and
if he didn't,
randy was going to molest him.
Have his way with them.
Excited about GSP.
Yeah.
I'm interested to see what happens.
Quite honestly,
I wanted to see him at 70.
I want to.
I think him versus Woodley is the fight,
like Woodley's had two fights in a row
where people were booing him and three
really because they had to fight with
wonderboy that will like chess matches
and then one fight with Damien Maia,
which was also like just not the most
exciting fight,
but I think him versus GSP would be very
exciting fight.
I think that's the real fight because
that's GSPS real weight class to,
you know,
I'm interested in that,
but I'm interested in the bisping fight
too because I think it's a tough fight.
It's a tough fight for GSP.
Bisping is a handful.
He's a big fella to fought at two.
Oh five.
And the ultimate fighter fights in one
85 in the UFC.
He's way bigger than George and he's
gotten fucking tough man.
He's real good.
Legitimately real good.
And George has been out for a long time.
Yeah.
What's he been doing?
Well,
he's been training.
He's definitely stayed in shape.
He did a lot of gymnastics,
did a lot of exercise,
you know,
he made a shit ton of money when he was
fighting.
He had contracts with Nike and he had
some.
He had a.
was it Nike or was it?
Um,
I think he had something.
I knew we had something with Gatorade,
but I want to say George had something.
Maybe it's under armour.
I think he's got something with under
armour.
Yeah.
So he's at a bunch of big endorsements
and he's at a giant hero in Canada.
I mean,
just giant.
Right.
So I think for,
you know,
a while he just recovering and then all
those wars,
all those years of getting brawls.
Then finally got to a point where his
body started feeling real good again.
It's like,
fuck it,
let's get back in there.
I wonder if the aliens are still around
the len to come to me.
I think red light.
I refuse to drink a gatorade anymore.
I used to drink a gatorade every single
day for the last 20 years and then the
other day busted wine open,
drank it,
and something that felt like a raw egg
went into my mouth and spit it back in
and it was just this low lob just shot a
this video on it.
It's apparently a thing like this.
The gatorade gloves.
Yeah.
It's actually,
I'm not the only one.
There's Kombucha.
See that?
That was in my mouth,
uh,
top
119 complaints and reviews about
gatorade from consumer affairs.
So.
So you got one of these brands in my
mouth and I saved it up until about a
week ago because I was going to just
call them.
And then I was like,
ah,
who cares about this hub?
What are they saying it is?
Whoa.
There's a load.
So much data loading there.
It was the grossest thing ever in it.
Seriously.
I have like flashbacks and I can't,
I can,
I will never ever drink a gatorade for
the rest of my life and look at this
crap.
This is a wow.
That's just molded though.
That's mold.
Mold is sugar or something,
but who knows how long that's been
sitting there.
That's one thing.
Whenever you go to a gas station or
stuff,
always look at the bottom of your
container,
like if you're buying like a plastic
bottle,
like apple juice or something.
Because I've noticed that ever since
then I'm so paranoid about anything and
I tell you half the times I'm looking at
the bottom like that does not look
right.
This looks like it's been mold or
something.
Things that are go traveled around like
a Mcdonald's or the.
The dude who was worried about Wendy's
with the hot trucks.
There are things that are travel around
in hot trucks,
you know,
like for real [inaudible] I wonder if
like what temperature gatorade has to
get to before shit starts growing in it.
And that's it.
I mean I did buy,
I bought my gatorade from Amazon,
you know,
so I was probably sitting in some hot
warehouse somewhere.
Just cooking.
No.
When it's sealed,
I wonder like what does that mean when
they seal it,
right?
Like obviously air's not get into it
right now,
but there's some air in there.
What happens to that air?
Right?
How's that era effect his shit growing
in that area?
Know how much.
I think there's chemicals in there to
make sure that nothing happens.
Like they found some 6,000
year old bottle of wine recently to see
that.
Yeah,
I think absolutely what they found was a
6,000
year old vessel that contained residue
of wine.
I don't think they found like 6,000
year old bottle that you can just get
fucked up on.
Imagine traces of 6,000
year old wine discovered in Sicilian
cave.
That's my,
my people there.
Make it a fucking night.
Show us.
They got a nice wine.
This guy has been growing wine for
16,000
fucking years.
You've got to get this wind and you get
this whining.
You 16,000
years is family's been overhead.
They used to have thumbs.
They used to pick the grapes with their
feet.
That's how long ago they did this.
These motherfuckers.
Wow.
Look at those.
Those,
uh,
pots that they found.
That is crazy.
Those are 6,000
year old pots.
They used to hold wine.
Cool.
Fucking find in Canada that's older than
go back to tempe or some kid found a
civil.
Don't don't change that yet though.
I want to look at this for a second that
just trips me out that those big vessels
or 6,000
years old.
That is so weird.
Man.
That is so fucking long ago to try to
pretend what life was like 2000 years
before Christ.
That's essentially what you're looking
at.
Or fourth that yeah,
4,000
years before Christ.
Six.
So 6,000
years ago.
No Christ was zero,
right?
So it's 2017.
Two thousand years past Christ.
They,
they,
they say current era bce be enough
fooling everybody.
We know what it is before Jesus.
You Fuck Keith,
why aren't you.
What'd you have it?
Oh,
just a coincidence that before current
ever era just happens to land.
Exactly on when Jesus came back,
shut up assholes with their bce before
current era.
What does that even mean?
Why can't we just start it?
We can't.
Can we go back and agree with zero is
and rewrite history.
I mean we decided that this was a,
you know,
the BC 2,500
BC,
they made the pyramids like what the
fuck does that even mean you're going
backwards?
So 6,000
BC is actually earlier than 2,500
BC.
You guys are retarded.
What a stupid way of measuring shit.
How about you go all the way back,
you make that zero.
You start from scratch because the earth
doesn't know what year we're in.
The earth has no idea what year were
deciding it in to do,
make some arbitrary number and have
everything before that.
Start with a low number and build high.
Like you have a like a flat line between
reality and some new dimension or like
water and air.
Like you have a hot number.
When Mr Software created zero.
One's a Christian monk.
Yeah.
I looked up the other day,
were alphabetical order came from and
who got to decide why it was that and
what made a before b or whatever the
fuck it was.
Some scholars back that,
you know,
when people couldn't write,
they were the only ones that could write
and read.
So they made it up,
you know what the craziest trip is,
man,
when people were writing an ancient
Hebrew,
they wrote with letters that also meant
numbers,
like a word also had a numerical value.
Like there was no numbers.
They didn't have like numbers.
They had a and a's.
Alcohol also won the bees also too.
I just thought of that time period and
no one else knew how to read.
So if you got a letter or whatever,
let's say if you got one.
Is that true though?
You'd have no one knew no one.
But I would say most people probably
didn't.
You might not think you have to read for
you.
You'd have to trust their translation.
That's all is great.
Your race and they were making pyramids.
They could all read amazing.
Yeah,
you might be right.
Right.
But that was the whole Martin Luther
thing,
right?
Lutherism.
Yeah.
He had figured out how to make the Bible
and translated into A.
I think it was German into phonetic
language that people could understand
because before they had to like trust
the priests or learn
Latin.
I guess I'm Lutheran or you really,
those are the super people.
They figured it out,
man.
You who were the ones that are
pentecostals?
Those are my favorite because they fuck
with snakes and shit was my favorite.
I like those.
That's hot weather of southern people,
man.
That's what that shit is.
That's all people that live in a place
where your brain is getting boiled by
the heat and you just decided to start
dancing with snakes and you know,
and fucking talking in tongues.
Samela elemental.
Ah,
they're sweating.
They're always sweating.
Pentecostal guys,
they're always yelling and screaming.
Yeah man.
That's a big conventions or something
where they meet every year to
pentecostals do the meeting,
swap snakes.
My snake and almost got me last week.
Every now and then one of them gets got
by a snake.
That's important to man.
All these people in the group have to
go,
oh,
okay.
Big Old party.
Look at that.
How much?
How much fuck,
Lord,
Gaylord opryland resort.
Shut your mouth.
How much butt fucking is going on?
Just Butt fucking in that room so much,
but fucking gold.
Go to that overhead view.
How much pray the gay away has happened
in that room.
At least 30 percent,
right?
Thirty percent of those people are just
trying to fight off the gay hard
Asheville.
There was a lawsuit that was just A.
I was just reading about where these,
uh,
this some sort of Christian cult.
They kidnap this guy and beat the shit
out of him because he was gay.
They were trying to beat the gay away.
Oh my God.
There's so much of that going on.
So much that pray the gay away.
What does this mother accused of having
Sun beat the gay away could face hate
crime charges?
Yeah.
Look at her.
Is that the woman?
Oh my God.
What is she going to talk about?
We should probably hear her talk.
Do you think we could get yanked a
report?
Yeah.
Let's hear what she has to say about
beating the shit out of her son.
I.
Yes.
I think that you was going to ask you,
but like I said,
I reported the water bed and another was
nothing.
Nothing was done.
And does it bother you if he does come
out to be gay?
Does that bother you?
It bothered me because he's.
He's a young age.
He's not.
He do not know right from wrong.
So yes he do.
Yes.
Whoa.
Is that her mugshot?
And right below the one that looks like
Katt Williams.
It's like James Brown,
Brown.
Get up,
get up.
What is that?
Oh,
it's from Whiteville,
North Carolina.
She lives in Whiteville.
Simulation theory.
Shit,
man.
North Carolina.
She's currently being charged with a
misdemeanor child abuse.
That's all you get for beating the
gateway.
Get misdemeanor child abuse.
He's 15 man.
That's Jesus Christ.
God Damn it man.
So a,
check this out.
That's even crazier right now.
Hurricane Irma holds about twice the
destructive energy of all bombs used in
the second world war.
Just 7 trillion watts of power in it
right now.
So why can't we get like some kind of a
windmill up there?
He can't collect it.
You would have to have a big one and
then it will become the biggest weapon
ever.
Well,
why don't we design that instead of the
galaxy note eight that no one wants to
buy it.
How about you buy a giant when windmill
thing and put it up there and make all
the power.
I have some friends that are in Florida
right now and uh,
the unforeseen problem that being out
here not knowing what to why and what
people are doing,
they're outside of an uncle in Orlando
who was telling me he's not leaving
right now because the roads are
gridlocked and the highway,
there's nowhere to go.
My friends who left Tampa yesterday got
up at like nine in the morning,
packed all their shit up and we're like,
all right,
let's go.
Where are we going to go?
They were like,
let's take side roads because it's
probably going to be busy everywhere.
So they did for awhile,
three,
four hours of side roads and then
eventually you're gonna run out of gas.
You gotta go get gas first place.
They stopped no gas.
They're all out.
So they continue on to the next one,
waiting a gigantic line to fill up.
But now it's again,
like hopefully we can live off of this
tank of gas for the next lesson until we
get where we're going.
And everybody has to leave right now
because the whole state could be
potentially under 10 feet of water the
whole days.
10 foot storm surge is coming and it
won't make it all the way to the middle
probably.
But it might fucking gigantic.
We don't know.
Obviously the only positive if there's
any positive thing compared to the last
hurricane is that it's not going to
stall over Florida.
It's going to keep on going and losing
energy the higher it gets.
But uh,
Orlando should be,
might get really fucked.
That's Disneyworld.
Disneyworld might be gone this weekend.
Right.
And they just.
Yeah,
they just rebuild it all or all this new
stuff too.
So.
Whoa.
Oh yeah,
there's that.
Ninety percent of this island of Barbuda
is gone,
gone habitable,
habitable,
Shawnee daily.
Even though some of the shit too,
because they can't see it.
It was all happening last night.
That can't get over to find out what's
going to get reports of it even.
Yeah.
They don't know if the people are dead,
they don't know shit.
Right.
I mean those islands are so small.
I mean,
what is this the size of like Texas or
Ohio or something like that?
It's A.
Yeah,
it's the size of Ohio.
The storm is 400 miles across.
It's how wide is Florida?
Florida's not 400 miles across.
I don't know exactly,
but it's probably.
I would go $300,
$200,
so it's going to be
like a giant eraser.
It just rolls up Florida
and they're still not sure it could turn
this.
Things can always turn.
It could go back and turn left and go to
Texas.
Grossest people that have ever lived
speaking for the people that go,
they miss,
they stay and they survive and the storm
miraculously turns now like I fucking
knew it.
No,
you didn't.
Stupid.
You didn't know it.
You're no better than the people that
get killed by it.
You just got lucky.
You know,
that's a lot of people in Houston.
That's how they feel.
They can make it a party.
They like,
they have hurricane parties and this one
really caught him off guard.
Did you know catch them off guard?
They saw it coming from days away.
Well,
they,
I think they in their heads think,
oh no,
we're fine.
We've been fine for years.
You know,
we're,
they're drunk.
That's the problem.
Yeah,
the fucking party and they're listening
to kid rock or on top of the room.
We don't care.
We'll stay up here.
We got a boat.
We're going to be fine.
We'll catch phase.
There was an episode I was,
there was an episode I was on,
I don't know if it was the last time I
was on or whatever,
but we were talking about floods in
Houston and I showed you that,
that,
that concrete or concrete pavement that
sucks up water.
I wonder if that would have been any
help if they had implemented that like
all over the place.
Maybe because I'm,
but I think the amount of water that
we're dealing with just so
unprecedented.
They showed the difference between
Hurricane Katrina and Hurricane Harvey.
Like the sheer amount of volume of
water.
It's insane.
Like this was such a big,
big hurricane.
That's just.
I wish there was a definitive answer as
to if all this is a direct result of
like human behavior industry,
car exhaust.
I wished it was a definitive result
where you could see it like,
yeah,
here's the number that you can show.
Will you show me here that concrete.
Oh,
the water drinking concrete where it's
as I do that,
it's mad,
crazy absorbed runoff from fast floods
if you're watching it folks,
the people that are just listening to it
doesn't even seem real.
It's like they have this giant water
truck and it's fucking pouring water all
over the concrete and it's just
dissipating almost instantaneously into
the concrete.
It's super weird.
I wonder if it has like a basement and
what it does is it goes through like
kind of like a concrete filter it and
goes underneath.
So the actual water is just like
underneath.
Yeah man,
what the fuck does.
It doesn't even seem real.
It seems like a scene in the terminator
movies,
you know?
Yeah.
Well either way,
like what they dealt with in Houston is
so much water.
I just doubt that.
I mean,
maybe that would have helped a little,
but I think that they're dealing with
just some insane amount of water.
Is that it shows what it is,
Jamie.
It's like some sort of filtration system
so it allows the water to go through it
and it can tell you that for us it was
probably too much water.
Yeah.
That harvey was a monster hurricane.
The crazy thing is how much bigger Irma
is like.
I think we're numb to it.
I think we look at it and it doesn't
make sense to us.
You know,
at 185 miles sustained winds for over a
day.
No,
no,
no.
It's just going to start rolling like a
cat.
No,
but here's the thing,
right?
Is this the strongest they can get?
No thing.
It's stronger than the category that
they attract.
This was the highest stayed,
gone and now this one is the new bar to
be basically a delta airline
accidentally flew through it yesterday
by mistake and it got out at the last
minute.
I forgot.
I read that this morning when I woke up.
Got Out.
Yeah,
I guess it accidentally was flew into it
and it was in somehow it got out of the
hurricane.
Is the pilot piloted his way out?
Yeah.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh,
I thought you meant it.
Got Out the pilot.
Did delta pilot flew through Irma,
one of those powerful hurricanes
recording all 170,000
factories are safe.
Why would they do that?
A No
on the fly to Puerto Rico.
Oh,
they had to.
They had to fly through it.
Did they?
Did they fucking judge it wrong?
Yeah,
they went through 185,000
mile an hour winds.
He imagined that turbulence.
Well it's not that fast.
It's 187 miles an hour.
Right,
right.
Fuck.
That thing is giant man.
When you see it on the ground or you
know,
in one of those overhead maps and you
realize how big it is.
Big.
That is so crazy.
So they flew through part of it.
Does it show trying to figure it out.
It's like,
yeah,
it's going right now.
Twenty five mile an hour winds gusting
for 40.
See,
look at it.
Whoa.
Hmm.
Huh.
So they were,
they were following realtime,
falling on a flight tracker.
Got Stuck in the actual.
Yeah.
Flew through the hurricane.
Oh my God.
That is insane.
Oh wait.
They landed.
Hold on.
Fifty two minutes on the ground in San
Juan.
They landed and turned around.
Oh,
they tried to make it back out of sin.
This is the airport has to climb out sj
you and they're doing so between the
outer band of Irma and the core of the
storm.
They went in between the bands.
Oh my God,
I need needs to be hugged by everybody.
So he went in between
bands and in doing.
Wow.
That's the most incredible thing about
weather satellites.
They can literally navigate this guy
through those bands and tell them like
where the storm is ahead.
Yeah.
They haven't
a portable dopplers here now in Los
Angeles to the where it's so accurate
now that you can just see your street
level of law,
like if there's a clouded in from above,
you look
at this while it looks terrifying.
Delta maintains that their pilots had
everything under control.
Our meteorology team is the best in the
business.
Eric's Snell,
vice president for Delta operations and
customer centered,
told The Washington Post dl three.
Oh,
two departed San Juan with 173
passengers on board according to Delta
Jesus Christ,
Pr for them.
Of course,
being on that airplane probably was the
worst flight you'll ever have.
Any really take a hard look at the
weather data and the track of the storm
and work with the flight crew and
dispatcher to agree it was safe to
operate the flight.
Would you do?
If you're about to get on that plane and
they're telling you what they're going
to do?
Shit.
All over myself.
I probably say I'll stay at the airport
and risk it.
Like,
fuck this man.
I'm going to sleep.
I'm gonna.
Take my backpack.
I'm sleeping on the ground.
I assumed that you guys turn this thing
into some sort of a hurricane shelter.
Have you been to the airport in Puerto
Rico?
No,
I haven't been to the San Juan one,
but I was at s one on the other side of
the island.
It's made of cardboard.
Not One of those.
You're right.
Getting the plane.
It's like a rundown Burbank airport,
but they got away with it.
Puerto Rico didn't get totally hit.
They only got like a little piece of it.
Yeah.
Well that's the thing about these kinds
of storms so you could just get unlucky
and it just runs right over your spot or
you can be right next to that and go
lord was looking out for us like,
okay,
you sure are you sure?
He just didn't get lucky.
Like we're dealing with impossible
forces.
Like a hurricane.
The size of Ohio is an impossible for us
like that.
I don't think we really understand what
the fuck that means.
I think that's one of those things that
when someone says a trillion billion
dollars,
like yeah,
that's a lot,
but you don't really think about it.
You know,
you don't really,
really understand what that means
because too much the size of the
universe too much.
The power that that thing has,
it's just too much.
It doesn't make sense.
You'd have to see it.
You'd have to be there.
Do you see the video?
I don't know if it's real either,
but the video of A.
I don't know if it was today's
hurricane,
this guy's trying to hold his truck,
like he had like a pickup truck trying
to hold it so it doesn't tip over and
the winds were so strong.
He just gets squished by hard to see
because it was raining so hard,
but it's got to be crazy.
Why would he do that?
A truck is about to flip and you think
you've got to stop it with your hands.
He watched too many movies.
Motherfucker can pick up a truck.
Can you pick up a truck?
No.
Then get the fuck out of there.
Put this on Youtube,
but we can watch it.
What is it?
Oh,
this is the guy.
Oh Jesus.
Oh Dude,
that's a wrap.
Yeah.
He's crazy.
That guy's crazy.
Look at that thing.
Fucking in the breeze.
You should've got outta there,
man.
Just sandwiched.
Yeah.
He got crushed.
He didn't handle it.
Well,
now you can't get out from under that.
That's too much weight.
You're dead.
Fuck.
It says fast ones.
I get me like that guy.
I probably just was like,
oh well my trucks and about boom,
you're dead.
Well,
the thing about these kinds of
hurricanes are how many of them can you
get in a row because if they're saying
there's two more in a row behind Irma,
2005,
I think it was they got hit for like for
Florida got hit like four times in a row
and like do you have a decent every
week?
Those were like twos and threes.
These are fives and you know Jose.
Jose is going right for Washington DC.
Hurricane Jose.
Jose is going gonna be a big one.
Do you think so we're going to do or
what have you been hit?
United States I'm worried about.
I'm all man.
I'm worried about earthquakes.
I'm worried about asteroids.
I'm worried about super volcanoes.
We're dealing with a small amount of
history.
That's what's going on.
I mean especially when it comes to
whether or history or the weather's like
what?
Couple hundred years old.
Like what's,
what's our recorded history of the
weather.
But if you had to guess what's our
recorded history of the weather?
18,
78.
That sounds good.
I'm saying something like that.
I'm saying somewhere around like 200
years.
They started figuring it out.
Does that make sense?
Yeah.
Eight stuffed down around Columbus where
they said 300 years and eight slash 18
slash 16.
I wonder when that can measure though.
Like when they knew they knew when they
were cold,
like fuck,
it's cold out one the one they knew what
that meant though.
Like if there was a number,
I guess we needed tools also to track
that rafter I've now seen in the year.
It makes way more sense what I just
found.
So,
um,
the invention of the thermometer.
When was that?
I don't.
Well,
I'll look that up too.
I'm a guest.
Seventeen 55.
That's good one.
I would say eight.
10,
12,
18,
12.
You're probably right.
It's probably more a more recent than we
think of mercury on the Fahrenheit
scale.
17 and 24.
But the first recorded temperature,
it says here was 1880.
Oh Wow.
In 78.
It was two years off.
That's amazing.
She probably had to have something,
touch it back then.
Touch the mercury and how they figured
out what.
I mean,
look,
we can't even agree on the metric system
versus inches.
What's interesting there then if that
was the first time they get ever
actually calculate the degrees.
Did they have measurement for degrees
before that?
Did they have like temperature
measurements before that?
Like what did they use?
Like when they were talking about like
how hot is a fire,
like what did they use?
They have no idea how they touched it.
That's super hot.
Oh that ice is cold.
Like did they have any idea?
Like did they even describe it in
measurement and eight.
The clinical thermometer wasn't invented
until 18.
80 18,
66.
It was probably some dude with a regular
thermometer just stuck it up his ass.
Somebody caught him and he was like,
I'll probably just making sure that this
thing works on people.
I said five minutes instead of 20
because it was up his ass.
Heated it up.
That's a 99.
They started in 1999 is when the
forehead thermometer came out and that
1999.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
I like this first temporal artery
thermometer.
Nineteen 99.
That's the one you put it on your
forehead,
right?
That's nuts.
That's just happened.
The crazy thing is
the idea that before the thermometer,
they didn't really have a number.
When they were talking about things
being cold or hot,
like did they.
When did they invent units of
measurement for temperature?
When was that invented?
Right here.
Because obviously there's more than one
right there.
Celsius and there's Fahrenheit and
Celsius is the one that's based on the
metric system that's used by almost
everybody except for us.
We're fucking assholes,
you know,
they'll,
they'll say something like,
oh,
it's 35 degrees out,
and I'm like,
what are you talking about?
That's not hot.
And you're,
oh,
your Celsius is.
What is that like 80
and 35 degrees.
It's hot as fuck.
Right.
That'd be cool if we all had the same
name,
like currency also.
It just costs more in different places.
I went,
why?
Why don't we just make everything
easier?
I'm everything because everybody's
corrupt and if we were all together,
someone would fuck us up and we would
lose all the money.
Someone would siphon all the money up.
They would,
they would weasel their way through the
whole batch of it if we have a bunch of
different factions,
a bunch of different languages.
Everybody's sort of keeps peace.
Hey,
and know like super wizard,
you know,
a despicable me character comes along
and hijacks the entire system.
The earliest recorded system of weights
and measurements.
What does it say about temperature?
I don't know,
but I mean Ted temperature take awhile.
Yeah.
But history of measurement is not what
I'm asking because I know that they've
had scales for a long time,
but like what about when was the unit of
measurement for temperature invented?
Got Length,
typographical math time.
It doesn't say temperature.
Well somebody had been like not have it
and then they had.
It must be a day.
Right?
And it probably would have started like
this is the temperature of red dead
raven or something like that.
And this is a snake in 16,
59.
Wow.
England temperature.
So what did they use to measure it?
What the fuck did they use to measure it
if they didn't have thermometers?
God Damn,
it's Freaky,
right?
I mean,
imagine not having a thermometer and
trying to measure the heat.
Sounds like your inner dialogue of you
at night at three in the morning I got
fucking problems,
dude.
Especially if I smoke a joint,
it's crazy how normal life can seem and
then you smoke a joint.
You're like,
oh no,
it's not normal at all.
It's so crazy.
A hundred percent life seems so normal.
And so like,
you know,
hey,
what's up neighbor?
How's everybody doing?
And then you smoke a joint and just
watch a little bit of news about aroma,
about any of these things are more
freaked me out.
The other night,
man,
I made one of them 2:00
in the morning instagram posts.
I was just going online and looking at
storm footage.
I was like,
what are these?
Just keep hitting over and over and over
and over and over.
Yeah.
I watched a documentary about our coral
and our oceans dying recently and it
freaked me the fuck out and it's all
based on like two degrees of temperature
that,
that it's doing.
Like the oceans are two degrees hotter
and I was like,
wait,
there's like 8 billion people.
Can we just all throw ice into the ocean
at the same time?
It would probably.
It thought that through.
I said that last night it was a job.
Somebody,
you know,
what we could do though for real is um,
apparently wearing sunscreen and the
water is fucking terrible for coral and,
and people don't give a shit.
Oh,
it's like an oil.
Never thought about that.
Chemical Sunscreen,
whatever that stuff is,
is,
it's
weird.
It's like the face beats scrubs that we
can't destroy.
Right.
There's a little.
Yeah,
those things it get stuck in your drain.
Yeah.
But um,
that stuff that they use for sunscreen,
like how good is that for your skin to
spray that chemical on there?
I never use sunscreen.
I have to use it because of my vitol I
go because of the different colors in my
hand.
Like if otherwise it's like,
it's like if you're a white guy that a
logo is not nearly as obvious as if
you're a black guy,
right?
Black people have it.
It's like it's crazy.
Contrast and if I don't do it also like
I wore this pigment in those areas,
so if I don't have pigment like where my
fingers are like and that shit gets
cancer,
you don't have anything that's blocking
skin cancer.
So we're like backwards dice gloves to
Michael Jackson gloves.
The conclusion from the media is
sunscreen is killing the world's coral.
That's laughable.
Like it says right here that 10 percent
of the global reefs are at at least only
10 percent and many of them are remote
and without tourists that even getting
near them.
And that study was done with artificial
seawater.
So that study is bullshit maybe.
And this was also a mashable.
So man,
I read stuff like that and the Eddie
Bravo,
Alex Jones comes out,
me and I'm like,
who the fuck is paying for that article
in here?
Fucking sunscreen industry bro.
How much money's in sunscreen bro?
Fucking mom,
who loves their kids put sunscreen on
their baby,
Bro.
Tell people.
Start thinking maybe they're right.
It's hard to know who's fucking telling
the truth.
There's too much fake news.
That guy's crazy.
GCS Don't know why.
Son Ran into the,
to his death in the burning man fire.
I'm going to guess drugs.
Definitely acid.
They had security around it too,
as what I was reading in bed.
Who knows?
Man.
That's sad though.
It's fucking sad.
It's a sad way to die.
And he tripped.
He did?
Yeah.
Like,
like,
like he was so fucked up.
Maybe he didn't see,
but he tripped him into the fire.
Oh No.
The next picture shows him like falling.
I don't want to see this out loud,
dude.
Poor Dude said he looks like every dude
at burning man has got that,
you know,
like new new age hippie look.
That's a sad way to diamond.
That's sad.
[inaudible] story.
And you would hope that he didn't have
like a mental issue and then took a drug
and then had that episode.
You know,
people that are like,
we're reality's already slippery for
them.
Like really strong psychedelics not
recommended.
Yeah.
But he could've just been that fucked
up.
And you have a big burning man in front
of you.
Like I,
I had been that fucked where I could
have thought that I was running into ice
cream or something.
Yeah,
for sure.
Right.
That's a problem with psychedelics.
Yeah,
and it's also the problem with a look.
Everybody's reactions to these things
got to be like elite,
slightly different.
Right.
And some people just aren't designed for
them for maybe one style of
psychedelics.
It's like some people aren't designed
for alcohol.
Some people did just dish it and drink
doesn't work with them.
Who knows what happened,
but that's fucked.
Man.
Imagined being there and watching that
kid running into the fire and just be
thinking like,
is this real?
Is it really running into the fire?
You're all fucked up anyway.
You're not sober.
You're not.
Even if you were sober,
you'd probably feel like you were on
drugs.
You're around all these people that are
tripping balls.
You're watching this thing burst into
fire and then you watch a guy run into
the fire.
You're probably like,
what is this?
Is this a movie?
Like,
what the fuck is happening here?
Whenever there's like an extraordinary
event like that,
you always feel like it's not real.
Like what,
what,
what's happening?
Like I don't expect this guy to run into
the fire,
see someone running the fire.
Did he run into the fire?
Like your brain is scrambling so hard to
process it.
That's why they say that.
Um,
people,
uh,
there,
when they see something fucked up
happened through eyewitness accounts are
so bad because so many people like they
don't even remember what the hell
happened there.
Just so shattered by it all.
Like what?
Yeah,
saw a story about a kid,
I think he's in the,
like the juvenile penal system in New
York or something,
but he's been used by the system to
convict like 35 people or something that
didn't do anything wrong.
And like the article was about the shit
he's dealing with.
He's being used how
I'll pull it up real quick because he's,
he's done something in like probably
they're using him to get his sentence
reduced.
Oh.
So he sets other people up.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
That's the weird one that they're
allowed to have fake crime and arrest
you for it,
but the FBI has done that with people
like talk someone into making a bomb and
then they give them the parts and then
they give them the bomb and then they
like tell them to go somewhere and blow
it up,
and they do it.
Then they arrest them.
You're not allowed to do that.
Right.
That's how are you allowed to fish
people?
They are.
They're allowed to.
Man.
That's like the old hooker thing,
like you have to.
Yeah,
it is.
Yeah.
They talk you into it.
It's a.
But they're allowed to do that now.
It's not like it used to be.
What does that term that I'm looking
for?
The old hooker thing.
Seduction,
right?
No,
that's not even it.
No.
No entrapment.
Entrapment.
Yeah.
Yeah,
but they're allowed to do that.
Now there's A.
I mean the,
the slippery slope is definitely going
in the wrong direction.
Like you're allowed to.
Like you could take a really
impressionable guy.
There was one guy they did it to in
Texas that was supposed to be.
He was very mentally challenged.
It wasn't a very smart guy and this is
the guy that they talked into a trying
to detonate this fake bomb that they'd
given them and then they arrested.
Oh Wow.
That's really fucked up dude.
Who was like super troubled and they
just didn't need it or resigned.
Fuck them.
You know you can mind.
Fuck someone in the name of religion.
You can mind.
Fuck someone.
He's a lot of different ways.
If you were a.
especially you got to think like the
FBI.
It's like super powerful organization of
people that have had decades of
experience in the field know how to
handle people know how to deal with
weird shit.
That Manson Shit's about to get
released.
I wonder how she's gone about.
She's going to hurt in there please.
I know.
And she's not gonna know any of this
technology.
Imagine that thing.
Yeah.
She killed a pregnant lady,
right?
Isn't she one of the ones that was the
tate labianca killings.
Yeah.
Wasn't she?
She.
She was the youngest.
She was the cheerleader.
How old was she?
I want to say she.
17.
Jesus.
I don't remember if it was late sixties
now,
like imagine that life going from being
a young teenager to your entire life.
You're in a cage and then all of a
sudden it's.
You're an old lady.
They go,
go ahead,
get out for a little bit.
You're like,
fuck.
Like that's a crazy documentary waiting
to happen.
I hope someone studying or help.
There's like a good documentary person
that's on that.
Yeah,
because that's a curve.
Raisie documentary.
I mean who does she live with?
Like maybe and filmmakers like,
hey,
you can stay in my van nuys one bedroom
apartment if I can record everything and
have some sort of a pay site.
Right.
The Manson House,
she turns it into a cam whore Manson
house.
To be a camera,
have to get out of jail for murder and
you're going to have the tightest pussy
known to man.
I don't know about all that.
She's probably been sticking hammers on
there for last 20 years.
It's just been locked up for a long
time.
Who knows what's going on in their fist
when for sure.
Definitely a few,
few different fists over the last 35
plus years.
Like when would the see the Manson
killings was probably like 45,
50 years ago,
right?
Wasn't it?
It was the sixties,
Seventies.
Was it not?
I don't think it was a seven day.
It was maybe tate labianca murders
Manson.
Nine 69.
Sixty nine.
A lot of shit.
Woodstock wasn't that when Hendrix died?
Did he die in 69?
That picture was in or that.
That thinks the 69 on it.
May third.
Want to say he died in 69 or 70,
but I don't remember.
People really do remember that and they
get Super Mad.
If you don't know bro.
July 27th,
19,
68.
Don't ever fucked that up again.
It's Jimmy hunters.
It's like John Goodman's character in
the big Lebowski.
Could just ask Syria,
but when he died,
good.
Ask Siri.
When did Jimi Hendrix die?
Jimi Hendrix died September 18th.
Nineteen 70.
Who off by?
I found out recently.
There's a.
there's a building.
It's still there on Franklin and
Hollywood where Charles Manson used to
live and run his words out of which I
didn't know he was doing.
He was a pimp.
Yeah.
Pimping girls to people that are staying
at the roosevelt color.
Me Badd.
Right?
Mind.
Perfect color me badd.
Remind.
I love click though.
Those are great and it can make a nice
mug.
Yep.
Painted a dolphin last time I say.
All right.
We should wrap this up.
I gotta get the fuck out of here.
I got a bunch of shit to do,
boys.
It's been a lot of fun.
Uh,
Brian got shows coming up.
I know you do.
Yeah.
November eighth.
I'll be at Marty's in Indianapolis with
a club,
Quigley.
And then the following day,
November ninth,
I'll be at the funny bone in Columbus,
Ohio.
And then maybe New York.
Dude,
I like that you're going out on the road
like just you and one other person.
I mean,
Kate,
that's a smart move,
man.
That's great way to build your act to
right?
Yeah.
It's fun.
Get Nice.
And we're doing,
like,
I just got back from the mall of America
and Edmonton did seven shows in five
days.
That was a workout that's like the best.
Yeah.
You get tightened up,
you know Brendan Schaub saying that to
me after he got back from Dublin and he
was like,
dude,
you just all those reps.
I'm like,
that's what it's all about.
You get those four or five set a
weekend,
weekends and you're like,
whew,
got it tight.
So great.
And every,
every,
you know,
sometimes you have two nights or two
shows a night and then you just,
hey,
I want to fix this in my,
like instant gratification.
No,
that's the shit.
All right.
Um,
that's it.
Desk squad.tv
for all your podcast needs and
memorabilia and powerful a stamps.com.
Still using them.
Oh hell yeah.
Stamps.com.
I'm wearing me undies right now.
All right folks.
We'll see you next week.
Bye.
Right.